[Music]
[Music]
hear ye
hear ye
hear ye
what's going on is the ninja talking to
you
lords put the crest up what's going on
y'all
sundays you know how we do
gaming fire what's up
lydian master what's going on gerald
mack my god you don't make me holding it
down man joe mac good to see you up in
here d floyd what's up dreadpool you
know we're gonna talk some pizza talk
nicks what's going on you know what i'm
saying atomic sands got the beats
rocking donald taco what's up yep
zagreus in the house we definitely be
talking about that gunka what's up you
know
so yeah we got some fun some fun today
phantom cracking what's going on i see
you let me know if my levels is good let
me know what's going on lydian master i
got you
yeah thank you thank you commanderodomus
what's going on
no doubt no doubt so we're gonna get uh
the legend hopefully get the legend up
in here soon jake valdino you already
know
arcade what's going on 4247 and then get
the rest of the realm in there smoke the
king see what's up with attic and solve
they ship it all pulling through thank
you thank you for the mic check respect
always cola what's going on but yeah we
got a fun show for y'all fun show for
y'all
very excited you know what i'm saying
and jake up in there and um yeah talk to
you games we got fun topics
i'm excited i'm excited ninjas
so i will be back we will get people in
the room get get your seat in the front
of the congregation it's the lord's day
and i'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target
[Music]
don't stop
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to
starter regardless back when you was
messaging people
[Music]
them to be your dog thing very loyal but
i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to
boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tiller uber
cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my
[Music]
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boil you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but coming to find
out that they really mechanical and yeah
i be eating these rappers but that's all
a part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't wanna be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
on twitter but i'm anti-social love my
city but i'm still by coastal
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog's thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ontario's
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine this cooler give
you some advice and invite your girl to
your squadron cause if you don't give
her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's an avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny words incognito who cares if
you fly if you're still a mosquito
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that joke king david
still be the king of the statues since
the juvenile i've been cursed with a
curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it and
nothing is cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen
[Music]
all right
hear ye hear ye and we are live
welcome to the iron laws podcast llc and
also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 221
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the front of the round table on
the lord's date i'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
hades at game pass id at xbox games call
2021 announcement and playstation plus
with crunchyroll to discuss so we're
going to get right into it
i want to introduce the lord who sonaldo
and myself had the absolute pleasure of
being in the flesh at pax east 2020.
not only is this lord the embodiment of
pure passion and the grind necessary to
succeed but whose content creation has
truly evolved into informative game
analysis movie retrospectives and pop
culture
introducing the creator and host of the
jake baldino youtube channel and
executive producer of the game ranks
youtube channel
the lord of metal gear and pizza
connoisseur
whose sneaker collection game will
forever be on fleek
he put the money by the ground
live from strong island new york new
york and making his official debut into
the realm of the lords
my man lord jake baldino how you doing
sir
dude that was like that intro was going
to make me cry that was so good thank
you thank you for that thank you guys
for having me it's been way too long
trying to make this happen and i thank
you guys for being patient with me no
doubt no problem no problem brother glad
you just fed it hello new yorker
exactly thanks good to have you around
versus the giants last night
new york is on fleek let's go
dude
otherwise i know we talked briefly but
to the realm you know whatever you've
been up to what you've been playing
what's been going on with you man
oh man uh i've been playing uh
a game called my job
i play that game every day
maybe eventually i'll get the trophy
i'll get of that
you try to plant them
in their job
one day
i know i've been playing a lot of stuff
i've been bouncing around i do that
thing where you go through
game pass and you just keep scrolling
and you download that you're like that's
great that's great that's great that's
great and then never get around to
playing
[Laughter]
right now though i'm playing art of
rally because that just dropped on game
pass
it's just kind of like super chill rally
racing but like with like a top down oh
you talking about the one like there's a
homage to sega rally that game yeah yeah
yeah that game is it like the cool art
style over the top almost like um
i don't know like a cartoonish art style
is that the yeah it
is stylistic cold sharp yes yes angel's
talking about it yes yeah and it look it
plays it looks really good it's really
yeah it does
it's crisp it's it's super sharp it uh
it's it's really difficult it took me a
while to really get into the flow of
like turning and drifting i think part
of it is just because it's like pretty
intense mechanics for driving but also
getting used to that camera angle it's a
good camera angle and you can adjust it
but just
getting used to having that view and
having the road in front of you yeah
it's exciting it's really cool but like
learning how to adapt is is kind of wild
but i've been loving it no no no doubt
solving we want to get the super chat
before we get into yeah absolutely give
me a moment we have breath with the five
dollar super chat salute lord smash that
like button everyone thanks
a little brother man flip flop there we
go and then we got ace out gamer two
dollar super chat welcome welcome jake
i'm excited for this show yes sir thank
you sir then we have log nets finest
flame five dollar super chat good
afternoon realm cog i do the usual but
we got royalty hope everyone has a great
show please behave we got company today
we got exactly
i gotta give a shout out to the german
shout out to lord sovereign and the
fresh baldy yes sir boyfriend the
boyfriend
clean the day
bone slave i see you what's going on
brother callie in the building bone
after we finish man we gotta get on
curse yeah stick around baby you already
know so now we got that out the way you
know we got the four horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the realm here
at the round table with updated
time-sensitive intros because jake has
limited time sir
but
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the ha of the young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good man i ended up uh you
know what you doing staying up a little
too late
shut up like the last three minutes
before i open yeah i was here yes that's
all that matters
just in time
yes that's all about that that's pretty
much all i'm gonna say what you was
playing though just real quick uh i've
been playing a lot of hades like
we're gonna get into that you know you
made some very some strong proper
confirmations on twitter that hadn't
been upset
i've
you got a certain community upset yeah i
i pretty much said haiti shits on uh on
return and i got so many people upset
because of it spicy spices that's not
nothing wrong that you just said
of course you find nothing wrong with
that just continuously let's keep it
going and of course
we have almost technical gaming lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sastradamus the lord of clarity and lord
patriarch of the iron bank my man lord
sovereign how we doing sir
wow
yes my apologies for missing last week
uh anybody who heard me saw that i
sounded like i was gargling gravel so
that's not not good not good not good
but i'm happy to be back chilling i'm
happy this despite my my little my
little uh flame meow post on twitter
yeah you look very spicy on twitter i'm
happy that everyone's playing haiti
a little while yeah
he is the alpha beta board like he is
the original man
wait what why is king the og
is the alpha and omega beta boy
this is a man that spent thousands upon
thousands of dollars to import consoles
sometimes
except for me i'm sorry i wasn't here
yeah he's catching up for his updates no
but i just don't want him to act like
like his not testing games out it's from
some elevated sense of like some oh i
refuse
okay
away
watch this this is not gonna end well
for him ultimate i'm just saying he's
the original time
time time we have time sir
that is all okay movie gone yes okay for
me
dominance maximus aurelius spencer said
no longer
[Laughter]
and on that note of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the excess
gamer
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
nothing less than the premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir we're
doing fantastic jake is here
all right if y'all guys don't know jake
has a fantastic video out of one of the
greatest zelda games that has ever been
produced and this beta tester boy over
here has definitely beta tested it just
for you guys this is right before i quit
the group um
that's when you
could be a debater boy okay
as you can see zelda felt the way today
he bodied mario
so mario have to feel a sword
today is the day mario's gonna learn
the next video for kos
is uh rolling out it's almost done you
know that video's done i'm editing and
stuff like now um you can go check out
uh kos it's up it has wolverine brown
suit wolverine
he's up here right now
um attic did a fantastic thumbnail mina
was going back and forth because i
wasn't sending him 4k thumbnails and
attic was really pissed off yeah your
image quality this week was weird
okay so that remember i got my new phone
oh that's right that's right i know but
i didn't update it yet because the old
phone it cracked in the back guys you
see that right there oh
that is messing with mine you know you
have a new camera right
well actually i do you see the boxes
right there yeah we me me and king are
slacking we will legislate i'm in this
i'm in the same boat
we got to get to addis level we
apologize real all right so let me get
really quickly into what i was playing
all right so all you guys know i'm
addicted to curse right now curse right
now is absolutely ridiculous shout out
to bone slay we downloaded the voodoo
master the voodoo master is an absolute
cheat dude inside the game okay all
right um this is curse of the dead gods
no no no no
i played that to curse um it's a like a
pub g type game curse
okay what is battle royale yes it's a
battle royale
all right so um it was me chris we
always have a team you can go into team
of five yes and when you get the zombie
dude right
the voodoo guy he calls zombies that
actually act as uh like little sentries
and they they follow around you they
shoot they can kill people too they can
run up on them they can melee them they
can shoot
it confuses the hell out of the opponent
because the opponent sees somebody
moving and they automatically shoot at
them right when they shoot they give off
their position zombies see people when
they shoot two gotcha so if you have
five people five people have uh
that voodoo guy that means they have
three zombies
you're running with a horde of people
and it's absolutely a chico we've been
getting chicken dinners the whole week
it was great um i played the the racing
rally game um all right hades getting
that really quickly it was fantastic we
had to talk about it we were gonna talk
about yet yeah it was fantastic it was
great um i gotta give a shout out to
phil dominus maximus to really expensive
um because i didn't have to play it in
uh 720 more there he go
yo thank you phil
he did that for you he did that
and of course i played my destiny and
got my outriders in because i'm outright
boy no doubt no doubt you already know
and of course you already know we got
the gaming ninja himself this [ __ ] don't
be lord cognito spreading that realness
in the roman iop not telling what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
yo shout out to defining duke man we had
a great episode please catch that it is
up right now on last damn media my boy
maddie and randall thor the man with the
million came through so salute to him
you know what i'm saying and of course
if you missed out i'll be back this was
on vacation this week but our last word
is up right now on iop check that out ty
guy travis said we had the homie wilhelm
scream screen was in the building you
know what i'm saying talking that to us
so check that out and um yeah finally
for me it's just been i got a little bit
of scent on so i would have shout out
valacon and your brother kaibatsu you
know what i'm saying that's it's really
fun right i saw that yeah yeah they
fixed the bug in it that like um all
right everybody other than the host if
they go to the world um they like they
gain zeroes out or something like that
yeah what it is is kai figured it out
you you have to launch um do not if
you're the host do not you have to
launch a saved game
there's two options like launch a save
game launch a new game if you launch
save game then that will not allow
anyone who joins into a race day
character
so that was what it was because they
were going to when i put new game and
volacon had like a level 30 character he
was like yo i'm getting a prompt you
know to overwrite my thing i'm like no
no no no no so then we figured it out so
yeah salute to that and then um also
he's in the chat right now lord jake
would appreciate it because he met him
in real life is lord sonaldo tv i want
to shout out him i want to shout out
lady sam congratulations
the future lord of the realm was
conceived lord tristan was born this
week in long island you know what i'm
saying it's absolute the future lord of
the realm put the crush up for sonaldo
tv my man
yeah he's up there so the baby
everything went smooth you know what i
mean and real quick so before we uh move
on with our jake but we want to get
these super chats now and then we put a
hard stop and then we keep it put
we gotta hustle and motivate two dollar
super chat onward and upward iop keep up
the great work y'all thank you my
brother you as well you as well you help
us out a lot yes
then we got gerald mack five dollar
super chat oh hell the iop shout out to
that statue lord kingstradamus yo king
super clean damn
boy hashtag better boys
no doubt why is our friends across the
pond say be top boy
[Laughter]
we missed you salute to the panel salute
then we have slow mo back slap five chat
the beta boys are going on tour tickets
are 400
700 for attic
king yo welcome back into the group but
your lead singer roll has been filled
wow i still got it baby i still got it
no doubt no doubt there we have kevin s
five dollars for chat what's up fellow
gamers 80s kid here tell king that they
also had to get my tv from the back oh
pause lg oh oled all day i feel sorry
for the tcl are you implied are you
implying the quality of tcl television
service is that what you're doing well
i'm just saying the lack thereof i don't
know
listen
to the chat be careful you know
that's why because all playstations
people need to play something good oh my
god you know they got a tcl that's just
it works for y'all
i'm savage continue song
otaku five dollar super chat king i got
that same exact phone and the same thing
happened to mine it's
then we have adam two pounds super chat
jake owes me more than 60 pizzas get him
king
what's going on here like your personal
delivery guy yeah
so i close out my videos i say pizza's
on me yeah oh that's weird okay
and we got dallas we got dallas man five
dollar super jack been a fan since
before level one much love to the lords
and jake baldino when i finally shoot my
shot for an interview pizza is
definitely on me that's how you probably
that's how you buy that we had to do
then we have kdk five dollars for chat
happy sunday lords i'm glad to see lord
sovereign and lord addict are back can't
wait to see how messy king is going to
get today
i can't not disappoint you kenny wasn't
happy to see [ __ ] was back
let me make a statement real quick let's
go okay king will be impressed by this
i'm here to say maybe we was a little
too hard on skyrid's sword
wait a
to be minute
the issues i had back then was the
motion controls there's still the issues
now oh yeah it's just i don't have to do
this thing anymore so right
and you know i i was after playing
because i was thinking why didn't they
just take that out entirely i forgot how
much of this game is motion control it's
everything all of it all of it was yeah
yes yes
and they just moved it to the right
analog stick so it doesn't fix any of it
but it's you know no no it fixes a lot
of the nonsense it's just still you have
to conduct it's in hindsight yeah you
know jake had a wonderful video i mean i
encourage everybody to go check out that
video yes um i watched the video i think
i watched the video like three times
honestly um because i was working and i
was doing it and it was uh cog sent it
to me like yo yo check this out
i was instigating because i know those
two have the beef between the zeldas and
king skyward sword is on his mount
rushmore and adam used to clown him so
it's funny that remastered as a child
you always wanted to swing you know the
sword like zelda you always did you know
we make those little like if you had the
little mask you know in being zelda you
was like
but you never got a chance to do it in
the game you got a chance to do it uh
was it great then
they got good with it later and they
fixed it up now um yeah it was a little
it's a like my initial same minor issues
that you had but it was like back to the
dungeons yeah and that back to the
dungeon feel was really good um
and that's yeah sorry i think that's why
it really hit me because like yeah i'm
not like because breath of the wild
lacked that yeah so i feel like it's
been like a decade since i've played a
zelda yeah that actually has proper
dungeons and it's like it took me like
the first dungeon was like it was okay
but when i played the second dungeon i
was like yo this is getting annoying
like it was like six hours i was in this
dungeon because i missed something small
but like i felt like in in breath of the
wild you could do those shrine megazord
things in like 15 minutes like they
weren't that hard at all and it it just
it was it's a night
not to mention i forgot the stories
actually decent it's not
like music
yeah the whole presentation is like it's
really good in this and he made me
really cause i had you know i went back
and i played it again uh listening to
the sound and you were like spot on with
how the sound was bringing in the
feeling like the sound was a extra
character that really took precedence
over it and i think that was because it
was on cd and so he was able to use the
orchestra and stuff like that yeah
yeah it was it was really done well i'm
and
to see everyone um actually start to
embrace it and i feel like it's usually
something special
bro like a homecoming yeah
the thing that sucks man is they use
this game to demonstrate the motion
controls for the wii
and it's like man if you would have made
this game like you made twilight
princess and like oh oh yeah everything
else
that it could be would have been the
goat zelda
it would have been one of the best
zeldas but like the fact that it still
is no it's just like look i i think the
world has spoken i i think
i would put this up i would put this up
to like where my girl's mask is but like
i can't i can't take it past that
because sometimes the motion control
gimmick is so
dumb i'm like come on man
like sometimes i'll put all right like
the time
to talk
the controls
like jake you can agree the control is
still clunky at times yeah well he did
say that if you watch this video i
didn't watch it okay so um you know and
he did eloquent a lot of the stuff that
you're saying but you got to transport
yourself back to a time when they're
selling a machine that is based around
move control and if you had the wii uh
remote plus on it it was actually a
one-on-one ratio it was one to one like
it wasn't there
no no keep going it's fine pretty cool
the way you can hold it up and it
charges you get that feeling like a kid
you hold it up you're like that's what
he's doing right now he's totally
satisfied he's charging them
exactly i'm done solved last two super
chats and we gotta get we got three real
quick we got optimus code unchained
fifty dollars
oh man i could have gotten five of those
ten dollar upgrades with this super chat
oh man
i opp is anti-consumer i'm done with
kobe and messi look at the code
then we have clayton's
salute jake baldino for the great deal
with bessie
hey
shout out to one of our sponsors
absolutely
yeah we have flame once again two
dollars super chat king was on the front
lines he was a skyward boy
this is true
all right now we got everything all
right we got to move on so now we got
all the lords caught up we want to focus
now on lord jake his video game system
history the journey to game ranks and of
course the be because video games
podcast and what let him create his own
personal channel so lord jay let's start
from the very beginning what were some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming
i'm really fortunate i can actually
pinpoint and remember the first video
game i remember seeing and being blown
away by it was uh it was at a pizza
place yeah and it was uh they had a
cabinet for x-men children of the adults
and it was like right at that time where
i was like really young but i was
obsessed with x-men and i remember just
sitting there watching the splash screen
you know and like the fight screen and
like
like a juggernaut would show up and i'd
be like oh my god it's got juggernaut
and then magneto would show up and i go
oh my god they got magneto i have to
play this uh so from that i was hooked
and then i i was lucky because
uh i was like you know i was born in
1990 so i was kind of like past some
generations but like money was tight so
like all i had was a nes
and i had an nes for a really long time
and i'm really glad i did because it
exposed me to so many things that i
otherwise
wouldn't have been exposed to because
now like i have to go back and play them
all but i was like there for that and
then after the nes i jumped right to
uh ps1
and it was such a hard transition
because i was like blown away i'm like
this looks amazing but like my little
kid brain couldn't comprehend 3d and
moving characters in a 3d space okay
yes
it like broke me but
from there it's just then i just played
everything anything i could get my hands
on don't care what was your first uh
games that you played as you know on the
ps1 that that you can like hark in the
back
uh crash bandicoot
jet motto
everybody forgets about jet moto yeah
that is so good uh attack uh what was it
cool borders played a lot of cool
borders
uh and then just demo discs
that was like a game definitely
yeah
yeah
right so you you transfer all right so
you got the long distance on the
nintendo
and you said it was a hard transition
because a lot of us got a chance to test
analogs and stuff like that with you
know other you know consoles and stuff
but your transition was straight into
like what the playstation was doing
which was great audio and incredible
fast 3d graphics right was you playing
any fighting games because you mentioned
children at adam
and
they did definitely get that game at a
period of time did you just run out to
get that game to get that itch that you
saw from the arcade
from there i remember i don't remember
how it went down but like not long after
i had seen that
i had gotten a nintendo uh an nes but i
i never really played any
fighting games other than at arcades oh
okay okay okay i was like oh this is
where the fighting games are because all
i had was an nes and that's right like
this i'm talking about when you guys
excuse me did you get children out of
adam to get that i actually didn't no it
was like it was such a long gap that i
had kind of like kind of like faded from
memory a little bit i'm glad i'm able to
like recall stuff like that no i was
playing like star wars masters of
terrace
games good game
let me back you up because you actually
had like i said you had the arcade shout
out to the pizza shop so all those great
spots that you go into whether it be the
grocery store pizza shop bodega whatever
right you know and then you get your
name yes whatever doubt there's a gap
then you said between nes and and then
that playstation did you experience any
other consoles whether it be from
friends or just in general like what was
that gap about
yeah i don't remember like the order but
i remember going to the kid down the
block his house and he had a nintendo
64. okay and i remember the first thing
i remember seeing was hello and mario's
face comes back you could like pull his
nose and stuff and i remember being like
wow oh my god this is incredible mm-hmm
and uh that i had always then
from then also wanted a nintendo 64. the
greed the greed started early where i
just wanted everything i'm like give me
give me give me you know
so they were shut they was shut my boy
jake down like the the paris was like
nah or just it was just the situation
just wasn't you know where you were able
to get all those or even maybe trade
with others or something like that
yeah it was like
money was limited and that's how i feel
like most of us i don't want to speak
for everybody but like it was so
different then because it was like you
would get one game
you would like intimately know that game
you would know every inch of that game
even if your first impression in a game
was that it wasn't that great you would
still
torture yourself with it because it was
your one game for like six months at
least good point i missed that you know
1.0 that good point and then also i
always look at that as the years of the
box art where it was so important like
there was no like resources online to go
to so your decision making sometimes
with that one game would be looking at
the box off whether it be the toys r us
or whatever place you go to buy games
you know it was it was just a different
time man
in saying that it was such a different
time and you said the box out all right
so the reason why [ __ ] is saying that is
we will go to the store
and based off of the box art you
wouldn't know if he was going to get
that game but the experience like jake
is alluding to is
see these guys get a get a bunch of
games a month right we got that one game
and we probably got it for our birthday
and then the next game was at christmas
and we got intimately involved with that
one game so it had to be a sure shot so
that's what magazines and stuff came in
and word of mouth but opening it
do you do you miss the manuals and stuff
like that and and the whole opening the
package of it because it felt it felt
really really good when you opened the
manual and you was looking at all the
moves and stuff that was in there and
they they went to the paper just one
paper and that kind of hurt me but on
the way home would be the best you just
like you go through it all you'd be like
yeah
i was that kid so when blockbuster would
put out new games right they'd put them
they put the manual in the blockbuster
box
but then usually somebody would take it
i was always that kid
collection i had a whole collection of
manuals and i i like i feel so bad now
look at this catching the limitations is
up and people like jake's the reason
they want to wait for that
i appreciate that
what do you open up a case from now on
and you see no manual
because you get it it'd be like damn
like what up because the menu was
everything would teach you how to play
and jake was like wario in the house
[Laughter]
he was like yeah man i lost that like
two months ago i don't know i can't help
you
here tell them when they call all right
you got a western union of money because
you remember what's the fact of the day
you had a western union of money for me
and i'll tell you how to do the movie i
understand i was a kid i was like pay me
in gum
[Laughter]
no doubt man so from playstation 1 any
other consoles in any order after that
uh i actually don't remember after that
it was just like full stop once i
started i was like i'm going to mow
lawns i'm going to do
odd jobs i'm going to save up get as
much money as i can to get every video
game i can
playstation 2 was the first one i
remember really busting my butt on and
saving up
because it seemed like such an
impossible amount of money you know for
a little ten-year-old kid it was like oh
my god uh and then from there it was
gamecube and i would bounce around
because then i started like selling
things and trading things
that's something that i'm kind of bummed
about now is that i don't have
a big old collection because i used to
always just hustle my way up to the next
new thing
and now i look back i'm like i wish i
still had my gamecube
let's see that's all right what you what
you were saying is all right so you
learn commerce right at that point in a
day you learn you know um this was worth
value and i'm i'm gonna get my money and
then you learn the barter system like oh
you have that and i'm going to trade for
that to upgrade myself here yeah right
and oh okay was you would you privy to
the sheist and gamestop
did you did you get a chance to bring
your console in and they told you it was
worth 35 cents
basically you understand the commerce of
training video games yeah learning how
to get robbed yes yeah that's exactly
what it was but i was so hooked i was
like okay i'm gonna take a hit on this
but then that means that i can get this
thing and instead of it costing me fifty
dollars it's gonna cost me thirty seven
dollars yeah that's a that's oh what an
amazing deal yeah i'm gonna go for it
fast
that's actually a good point because
that was so much part of the culture
back then you made a good point too it's
like
our kid buy and think oh man we're
getting over with all i gotta do is give
all this stuff away then i can get this
new thing that i really want for a
little less money but when you really
look at how much you spent for all that
past stuff that you are now trading in
at a reduced value
it's crazy man yeah because he he he he
said what i feel
i don't have all those old systems
because you know so i already told you
i'm the original alpha beta tester right
oh my god yeah and i had neogeo cd every
iteration i had neo geo console edit
every iteration
um every genesis
every iteration and
it was always sold or traded to go up
right and at the detriment of myself
my older self later on now i go back and
buy these retro consoles
that i've had already
just but they but the retro consoles
which is good excuse me
works on my hd televisions now we would
have had to do so much converting just
think about it jake to put a super
graphics or turbo graphics on our modern
televisions now and it'd be it wouldn't
look good for us no it's chaos
absolutely so that again so yeah i get
gamecube all that other stuff and then
from that point on it was just full stop
every console i'm assuming it came out
32-bit error all the way up
yeah just chasing that chasing that good
stuff nice uh the only thing that was
usually always out of my reach were the
handhelds i usually could just never
scrape by enough i was always kind of
behind on the handhelds uh
i didn't have
a psp kind of borrowed a friends okay um
i had i had a ds the original ds
and i didn't think it was that great it
took a while for it to kind of pick up
steam okay
consoles though consoles i was always
just trying to gobble up anything
anything i could and then eventually
once i learned the world of pc
forget about it
it was over no doubt man good good
gaming history like that you you kept
that consistency at that point picking
up yeah what's up getting a game boy uh
if anyone in the chat wants uh
uh wants to get washed at a pokemon
he randomly just called out anybody
anybody can get this word anybody can
get that right
so let's salute the addict for putting
the challenge out but um yeah man so i
just want to get into obviously great
gaming history now i want to get into
the content creation aspect you know i
mean as far as like you know what
inspired you to kind of transition into
that and correct me if i'm wrong
initially you were kind of more in that
like comedy space as opposed to just
like the gaming space
yeah that's true so i had i had uh right
after high school
i had a friend named eric striffler that
was a youtuber and he made videos and
stuff and i kind of got on board with
him and i got a taste i was like this is
really fun and i can i can be myself and
i can just talk about
stuff i love and goof with my friends
and
i had a lot of fun with that and that
started to grow and at the same time i
also was pursuing
video game stuff video games were still
ultimately what i really wanted to crack
into so i started trying to write for
small sites because i i was i was pretty
okay in school with writing you know i
enjoyed it it was like the one thing in
school i could like i could nail no
problem it was just once it started to
become like it was like a job and you
have to write yeah it didn't really
click with me so i pivoted to video and
through doing pretty much it is what it
was originally called uh
doing that with my friends
that was just like all right now i'm
just going to keep leaning into video
game stuff and youtube and you know and
now i think i actually missed the
anniversary but i've been uploading
videos to youtube now for over 10 years
wow which is crazy so you even say that
out loud it's so weird it's so
interesting like to see you know people
grow up in the space you know because
we're a little older it's insane it's
insane right it's insane what's what's
crazy is you you grew up with uh youtube
through it's like rebel age like
yeah
it's the wild west yeah people don't
understand like it's bad now but it used
to be like
like at least we have like semi of an
understanding of what's going on now
yeah but back then youtube was still not
in the in the no they didn't tell you
anything so you just had to experiment
with everything to try to figure out
what was working and we came up with all
these weird like like theories and stuff
it's like oh we upload like this because
it might do that and it might fix that
and then maybe
little things like that you just come up
with uh that and and also just like it
was so bad
just their back end and everything that
you would do like saving video tags
titles uh uploading a video uploading a
video could take days
processing could take days
completely people don't realize how good
we do have it now that's a good point
it's actually a good point completely a
different time than the things you must
have experienced to now to see that that
transformation has to be very
interesting coming from your perspective
and kind of grew with the platform right
so what i want to ask you now transition
now
obviously a lot of people in the chat
they they saying they love jake jake's
the goat and paris and everybody's in
there love it jake now a lot of people
when they first got in contact with
obviously game ranks right so like how
was that experience for cause from my
understanding again you were hired by
them and then just going through that
creative process what was that
experience like getting the whole game
ranks game
that was that was a whirlwind you know
and i i i talked to you at pax like
about this we went pretty in depth uh
and that was a lot of fun i was like
like when i met you guys at pax like
i've been thinking about you ever since
like it's weird i know that sounds
creepy no no no no no that's fine we
like keep the laws keep
i had been wanting to like break into
like a gig like i was making my own
stuff my own youtube videos and stuff on
games but i kind of wanted to do it for
a site like i wanted to be like the cool
ign video guy or like do something like
that you know
so i was gunning for that really hard
and trying to build up a portfolio and
stuff and i was applying to stuff i got
an interview
uh in
where were they the village i don't
remember where their office was but i
got an interview at kotaku
i got
bodied like i was not prepared
i just was too green i was i was too
green i got my foot in the door okay but
i was just too green
and it was a learning experience i was
like all right time to get more skills
try and you know get better at doing
voiceovers get better at scripting you
know build things up um and then i just
kept you know trying to make stuff uh
put stuff out there and then uh i saw
someone put out a thing for game ranks
they were looking for a video person
they didn't really have a youtube
channel and they wanted someone to build
that up so i sent them
a video of what i do and it was just me
being like hi i'm jake i do this and
this and this and this and i would like
to do it for you um and then the
the the owner the main person of game
ranks brought me on and uh we built it
up together and now it's like snowballed
into this big crazy thing and now i just
work there and hang out that's fun i'm
just happy that like i could pay my
bills and
that's all i ever wanted with it and
it's fun and now it's like way beyond me
like now there's so many cool people
there
that you know make amazing things and i
i sometimes i just kind of sit back and
i'm like in awe of it all right you
you've come a long way and again you
know shout out to addict and and put me
on from from back then too like the the
top tens and you know what i'm saying
before you buy like you're like the
before you buy guys
yeah i am i'm literally the guy in the
comments yeah what's funny is like i
didn't know your name at that time and
he was like yeah we're getting the uh uh
i i searched you up on google and he
said uh when you said your name about
the pax and i was like oh that's the
before you buy
but it's so cool to see like i said your
your star kind of shine and and be
synonymous with that and then you know
against providing such informative
material and things that people latch on
to in the gaming space it was really
cool to kind of see that all develop for
you and like i said it's been a
tremendous part you see everybody in the
chat shout out to milestone pianist
bless up salute like you've got to
follow him rafanzarelli's in there paris
like people have grown with you in the
space brother like there's no doubt
about it so salute to you on that what i
wanted to do yeah no doubt no doubt what
i wanted to transition from that on is
obviously we're talking about google we
talked about youtube in the early stages
like you know how is it as far as like
being as a content creator being
beholden to like one platform initially
right because we know a lot of people
you know the algorithm is rough out here
trying to figure out you know how to do
you know what to do what to content to
do you know so like how do you value
yeah get out of because i was gonna say
not to mention once you figure it out
they change it yes okay so like how do
you balance that like from going to
trying to great content that you know
maybe that you think will hit
versus sometimes things that you may
want to do that may not necessarily hit
that algorithm so to speak like how do
you deal with that from a from a content
creation standpoint
that's
it's been interesting actually it's been
a learning thing especially with game
ranks is that like uh the person who
founded the site and then helped me like
build up the channel uh we had a good
uh work rapport like a good workflow
where
i understood that like the
game ranks as content and their video
content it's like top tens it's trends
it's searching it's seo stuff and then i
try and bring a little
humanity to it and there's like a push
and pull it's like we gotta do these
types of videos okay but like what if we
make it like this so then people
actually like it um so it's been a good
back and forth doing that while also
trying to navigate the waters of
cube algorithms and stuff it kind of
broke me because now with my stuff i do
on on my channel my personal channel
i've been uploading there forever but
like i've made it a priority now
mostly out of fun but also really just
to see
how i can abuse the algorithm because
it's like all day at game ranks right i
spend my time
doing the algorithm and like like
worrying about like how to title videos
and stuff so then for my channel i just
go all right how do we break this let's
tank this
what kind of video could we put out
that's just gonna
not work and let's see how it does
anyway and it's been kind of satisfying
jake's talking about i i learned a
hundred ways not to make a light bulb
that's a salute to him because again
it's that it's that push-pull i feel it
again you know looking at the day-to-day
content then there's content that
sometimes doesn't do well initially and
then you know like was it like the
evergreen content and then people come
back to it and stuff like that so it's
so much going on and then obviously you
know with other platforms you know
patreon and other things and all the
different sources it's like this
balancing act but you actually
transition perfectly what i was gonna
ask you was your personal channel right
so you know how did that move come about
and then growing that the the person the
youtube jake baldino channel
so i've always
i've had that channel for a really long
time even back when i was doing pretty
much it with my friends i've always had
my own channel i was always making my
own stuff and it would go through ups
and downs you know because it was i was
always working on other things
so
the time i ended up always spending with
that
it kind of just ebbed and flowed and
then it was dead for like a year and a
half
because i was working so hard with game
ranks and just doing that that i let it
kind of
and
so
i think it was at the start of the
pandemic uh it was actually they
announced um
tony hawk's pro skater one and two
remake and it's like my favorite series
ever and i was so excited and the way
game ranks works is that we don't always
do videos that are like breaking news
this happened like we don't really do
those types of videos so i was like i
gotta talk about this somewhere and i'm
like oh yeah that's right dummy
you got my own channel
yeah i could do that so i i started
uploading from there again and it's been
more this time now uh
for sanity you know like it's like i do
a day-to-day work at game ranks and then
on my channel i i literally will just if
i feel like making a video a video about
this i'd do it i put it out there
because that's how youtube used to be
like that's how i started i just went on
there to talk about what i loved
and i kind of had to find that again so
it's like you come to my channel and
it's like yeah like mostly i make gaming
videos but then every once in a while i
want to make a video about
batman begins for no reason
right or delorean's like i just whatever
i want to yap about
i do it and it's been so much fun and
people are you starting to get it let me
let me ask you a question jay all right
because you're going into the whole uh
cathartic uh feeling of youtube as far
as getting uh what's inside of you out
right and then you're at gamer ranks and
you know you you have to um
do the format whatever pops up
whatever's on the board stuff that you
have to do and stuff like that blah blah
blah turn into a job turns into a job
right and then the pandemic comes
and you're like confined to the space
everything is starting to be limited
you're starting to feel the walls
closing in
and
boom tony hawk pops up
and you're like i got to talk about this
you get the feeling back you get that
thrive back you get that pushback and
then you realize i got my channel and
you run right back to your channel and
then all the energy starts to come back
uh did you feel rejuvenated when you
went back and started making your videos
on your platform to talk about the
things that jake cares about that's
inside of jake
oh thousand percent thousand percent
it's it's it's almost like therapy yeah
it really is and and i'm doing it
different this time different approach i
have somebody helping me out behind the
scenes and that's been kind of fun just
bouncing some ideas off of someone i'm
like oh that's new too like all this is
new so it's like i'm still doing the
same stuff where i just turn on a camera
and i yap but
with a little bit of a different actual
mission statement behind it every single
video i mention it as kind of like you
know people always say like hey and
while i'm here uh click the like button
and subscribe like in the middle of the
video yeah right i always try and
sprinkle in like i'm just talking about
what i love and if you appreciate
hearing somebody
talk about what they love yeah like come
on board
get attic you want to jump in okay yeah
because um
it's one thing i don't think people
realize when it comes to like youtube
is just like people only see the after
results they don't see the during making
the video they don't see yeah prepping
the video they don't say okay you look
at us like you're writing
whatever kind of bullet points or any
scripts and then it's just like they
don't understand like
putting all that on paper or on you know
a tablet into like a voice format to get
to the video like
it's very time consuming
people people think literally that
people do this in a couple like like in
30 minutes to an hour yeah and then
they're all they in the comment section
say why didn't you do this why didn't
you do that and then i'm like and then
i'm like why don't you have a youtube
channel bro
and what jake said attic you're on fire
because what jake also said that
resonates with me is that you know
during that period you know he's he's
climbing right and he's putting out this
contact but he's also it's almost like a
dark period but people don't realize
like you're so focused on improving and
getting better your personal life is
kind of not in the picture like it's
almost like your head's down and it's
just content content how can it make it
better and stuff like that and let's be
honest sometimes we ain't getting the
best sleep
eating the best and you know what i'm
saying like because the grind is real
because it's like you finally start to
see success and you start to hit that
button and it's head down from there can
you understand and relate to that period
of your life jake oh yeah yeah i have i
have something i call the dark the dark
ages or the dark period where like it
was like the first two years of game
ranks or so and it was really crazy and
we were building like crazy it was like
i missed
family events i don't really remember
anything like it was just this period in
my life where nothing happened
no forward progress of anything other
than
the work yeah and
it's good because it built things up but
it's the problem is also like you know
the the bigger you get
the more catastrophic any little mistake
is you know you can't preach
or anything like that and we do
we screwed up yesterday so bad in a
video one of one of our guys said that
gala galahorn was in destiny 2. oh no no
it was not yeah
i gotta
[Laughter]
you know and i think that's part of what
also is like you know you burn yourself
out but then
on the flip side there's also like you
just see glimpses of
of a human like you know our videos are
a little rough sometimes there's little
editing mistakes but we keep it there
because it's like hey it's just people
no no i think that's the reason that
people gravitate towards gamer acts in
general because like
you could every video you could feel
some form of personality in it like for
the most part i've never watched any
video
on that channel and felt
this is a robot talking like it's always
felt like genuine
just people making videos about stuff
they love and a lot of places you don't
get that man you if you you you know you
a lot of outlets and stuff it really
just feels like they're just reading
something behind
behind the camera and then they just
move on
it's hard too
oh sorry go ahead no no i just like the
fact that you touched on the burnt out
because you know people don't understand
like
the more you do it's like a candle
right and if you're not putting wax into
the candle you're going to eventually
get down to the bottom of the candle
right and if you're just grinding and
you're just grinding you're grinding
you're just burning you're just burning
you're burning but at that same time
that she was burning you was learning
where you were at see i like to go right
back to the channel because
each and every last one of us do certain
things outside of the channel right
outside of iop right cog does the last
word he does define in duke um sovereign
we do round tables um reviews with the
lords we're gonna get back to that
that's why he's such a huge movie fan
and he's anti the crap that i'm into
like you know disney plus and stuff like
that and hbo
the platform that you have and attic has
his channel that i feel like is you know
helps with a lot of things because you
know my child actually what i really
don't like just to say this though but
my child actually loves to watch attic
play games actually does right and yeah
yeah he does he he's like he's playing
daddy i'm like man get out of here
is that another f-bomb daddy
i don't i don't cuss so much
very good very good he cut it down um
he's actually you know i let my kid
watch him um
but
i say that to say that when you uh
learned all the stuff that you learned
over here
and then you said you wanted to do a
whatever video it could be like a pizza
video like you had a balm pizza i'm
working on yeah all right so we're gonna
get it in some pizzas right
let me do this video about this
that's that joy
and it was a period of time when i was
going through a transition because when
you statue collecting you get into the
oh let me do the next statue
right so oh who's first out with the
statue that's not my platform
my platform is talking about characters
that i love with some personal yeah you
always had that backstory character and
right and i had to step away because it
was a period of time where people was
like oh no kos this week or oh no this
the pandemic was like you know crushing
in
and you start to start reevaluating
yourself and then it's great to hear
that you found you yeah you found you
again and you with all that knowledge
that you had here you brought it back
here and the spark is like in flames so
you're back you put more wax back to
your candle absolutely and um i just
find that just really refreshing to hear
that somebody felt that they was like a
little burnt down a certain area and
they got rejuvenated back here and that
tony hawk that love of that game
i got to talk about it
i think
there's something that i realized now
that you guys at gamer ranks game ranks
have been doing it forever and
it's and it's the
it's the fact that you have all these
creators on there just talking about
stuff that they love
i was looking at giant bomb right john
brown has recently had like a big shake
up where some of their founders left and
and the entire format changed and now
they have this format where it's sort of
like a variety show type thing where
it's like they have their regular
podcast but then they have weekly shows
from different creators that have their
own channels they have their own things
going on and they're but they're on the
giant bomb platform so it gives it that
variety they're just basically shooting
the crap about stuff that they love to
talk about
um
but it it's it's real in a way that it
doesn't feel produced with like with
like this overall sense of like this is
our mission statement for this this is
our mission for this platform no the
platform is open and everybody who comes
in
and makes and makes content has their
own mission and i think that's great
because i think if there's anything to
figure out about youtube it's that like
the
the you and youtube really matters yeah
so let me ask you a question jake like
since you have so many different variety
of content creators at gamerx is there
ever time where you had to like
negotiate with solo because you wanted
to make a video that they wanted to make
too
no i
that's a good question no not really
we're pretty like it just kind of works
out it's actually been pretty nice
there's never really been any any
friction which is well not friction you
know just like oh you know like scout
because if skyward sword came up and i
already got jesus
i'm gonna i'm like no
you're not worthy
i'd like to make that video i'd like to
make that video oh my god because we do
that in the background like topics that
come up for the week
and
i'll i'll post without looking exactly
who put something and saw will put a
thought we'd be like yeah oh bro
i got that
damn it
i remember i remember one week it was
like really really dry and king posted
three topics and then we were like yeah
solves got that addict's got that yeah
he's got that he's like why don't you
just pick mine i'm not looking
where king is the king is you gotta beat
king to the to the playstation smoke
topics yeah he'll he'll jump on them yes
and it's like oh man here we go this
one's going to go left you got to get
them before himself
people might start saying you that xbox
dude that only talks about playstation
movie
and the second part about that is i'm a
real playstation dude yeah yeah yeah
first day
so move it over real quick got a couple
more questions i want to ask yes jake
and um because video games podcast
you're in the podcast space man yeah you
know so talked about that lord andrew
right like what's going on how did that
happen
so that's been a different approach too
that i i've been trying where
we do it
and that's it we just put it out there
we don't promote it we don't push it
we just do it and if you're into it you
show up and you hang out and we have a
good a really good discord community
nice around that podcast but uh it's
been one of the things i've made that is
the least
least numbers
uh not numbers focused like no doesn't
matter we just put it out there it's an
hour-long conversation between two best
friends we've been friends since third
grade
so actually the other day i told him we
were we were sitting here because he
works at game ranks too uh and i was
like hey you remember when you
introduced me to metal gear salad and he
was like i did
i was like yeah you don't remember that
he's like no i was like we were in like
fourth grade and you were like you gotta
play this it's like mission impossible
but you're cooler and i was like okay
and then that the rest was history and i
had to like remind him and he was like
oh wow i guess i did you're welcome
it's those stories man that chemistry
between friends and stuff like that so i
love podcasting with these lords here
you know what i mean it's good i need to
do it more yeah like just in general
like that's why i like i love doing it
with you guys i need to like just talk
just you know we don't work off of so
game ranks doesn't do
uh you know we try to avoid full
scripted videos right a lot of bullet
points and stuff because
it then sounds like a real person right
right but you're still at the end of the
day like making sure you get things
right making sure you say things and
it's like a podcast you just you just
yap yeah and
it's so nice it's it's great it's great
man salute to you on that and i love
that you're doing that talking about mpd
so bad
those are your people no no no no no
i see you all right we're getting let's
focus on jake right now
one last one also too
is the the negative
machine of content creation right and
one thing i've seen you know you
specifically kind of made a conscious
effort to kind of like you don't really
engage in that right and we know you
know the the faces and everything's
terrible and you know
we let's be real when it comes to the
algorithm right and it comes through
a lot of that stuff what you're saying
he didn't jump on the hate train right
off the bat
clearly if you look at his content he's
made a conscious decision so my question
to you is why
resist that type of content when let's
be real a lot of other content creators
are successful doing it why is that
important you to resist falling into
that
because i just i just like this
that's why i'm here that's why i'm here
there's no agendas there's no anger
there's things that are worth calling
out and like game ranks does we still do
videos every once in a while like this
these are the worst games or we call out
you know
battle battle front uh when it had the
big loot box issues there are things
that need to be
yeah you gotta you gotta like call
things out but
there's the whole real reason that we're
here like even just some of the crazy
deep arguments that people get about
games so loses the thread that like
we're just
and it's so hard to like not always try
and push this and sound like oh i'm
above right i'm above this or anything
but like it's just for fun that's it
that's why we're here that's why like i
picked up game informer or egm or
nintendo i flipped through the pages
endlessly until the pages ripped because
i just i just like this stuff he wanted
something he owned and stuff man it's
about the game my brother at the end of
the day we gamers that's what it should
be about mental health exactly oh yeah
okay this thing is driving me nuts what
the hell is that on your left shoulder
oh the hot dog
oh it's a hot dog that's a hot dog
yeah oh okay all right
cardboard
from the side right because i have um
this miles morales statue with venom and
it looked like venom mouth
he's like
got him stuck
when you look at the statues like you
see it but i don't know what it is from
the side so i'm just sitting there like
i just i just lost me absolutely i just
love how jake is like it's a hot dog man
yeah
and i'm pretty sure that a lot of people
in the chat is like what is that
honestly yeah people ask it's it's from
uh it's it was stolen from a target
about the food section of target
target
taking manuals and he's taking hot dog
promotions
[Laughter]
interview gaming question for jake it's
um i need you to clear the air there's a
raging debate going on lord jacob and um
the realm needs to know they need to
know if you're going to tell these evil
chicago pizza lords why
new york pizza is far superior than that
lasagna that they call pizza
can you
set the record straight once and for all
legend just rep new york real quick
never mind my bias but just if you could
just set the record straight
and i i mean all this respectfully like
it's
it's good chicago pizza is good it is
good it's just too much it's just a lot
and
i think part of the the new york style
pizza and like what we like about it is
the the utility aspect of it where it's
just it's always the same wherever you
get it it's always a varying level it's
always the same uh you can only get a
couple things on it there's only a
couple things you're gonna put on it
right you take it with you you eat it
you shove it down it's like two dollars
it doesn't matter
but it's like that's it you know it's
like a cup of coffee like i feel like
it's like pizza and coffee it's like
that's it and i've been struggling a lot
more now with this as you know you know
like i have like a a lot like a
growing audience and you know like some
followers on twitter and i think
i've gotten so much pushback when i just
i used to just tweet out a piece of
pizza and everyone will be like
oh my oh you sweet baby
now
i tweeted out and i guess because i have
people following me from so many
different parts of the world there are
people who are like what is that
and i'm like you don't understand
they're like who eats plain cheese pizza
i'm like i'm not from virginia it's
different here like that's no offense to
virginia but like
my thing is if you can't fold the pizza
and you know and in new york pizza you
fold it it's stick out that it's let's
take it out yeah poke you in the eye to
take your eye out yeah you understand
like i can't flop
but you know what you go to boston and
you pick up a boston pizza you fold it
and flop and lift it's limp
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're about efficiency
there you go make sure that you have
that weapon just in case somebody wanna
pull you
poke them in the eye
back up off me while i drink my coffee
i'm glad lord jake has set the record
straight we needed clarity you know what
i'm saying or the new york style dude i
could have disrespected the virginia
slander
i didn't even know virginia made peace
on my back
the question that also wants to know
top five we got to get into it man
top five video games or franchises of
all time for lord james i know what one
is
oh wow i haven't done this in a while
i'm gonna stumble through this uh metal
gear solid number one oh okay
uh number two tony hawk's pro skater
is it the franchise or just the just
itself
any particular yeah i played i played
most of them actually well i played all
of them and i feel like you're trying to
lead the witness again yeah i'm just
asking them because you know it was one
and two that got the juices flowing so
i don't know if it's the franchise
that's four it's four that's his
favorite one
you're you're actually right you're
correct it is
you nailed it yeah
you watch it
nice
yeah so okay so what did i say tony hawk
told me
resident evil
max payne
first back pain from iop first off is
like
yes
yes
uh and then uh can i say spider-man
games i know they're like franchises
i play every damn one even with
matchmakers
every single one i love every minute of
them even when they're not good i just
can't i can't get enough of it a
question question since he said
spider-man leading the witness i'm just
i'm just asking a question
out of all the spider-man games which
one is the best in your opinion oh see
told you yeah you already know this is
good here you go uh
yeah i do have to think it's it's
probably it's probably insomniac
spider-man oh king
the king is loving you that's what it is
he's
you know why you surprised
why he had to think about it because he
could have said maximum carnage because
i'm pretty sure it ran through your head
and web of shadows
okay so it's these games that we have
they act like all the spider-man games
was bad no that was only when they had
fog at the bottom of the floor and we
couldn't go down
yeah that was that but you know they had
really good games going through so i
just wanted to know
being that you did play from back then
and you know you don't have recency bias
you know like a lot of people
i just wanted to find out
yeah for me the undeniable thing about
it is just the
it told like a
peter parker s peter parker story yes
and that stood to me more than anything
yeah like the graphics are amazing you
feel like spider-man when you're
swimming
but it was the story it told that was
like i was like this is ripped from the
pages this is so good yes you know what
i also like about that the dlc
continued a great story too it was like
each dlc was something that you wanted
to purchase not something that you felt
that you had to purchase but it was
something that continued a great story
going through and i thought they did a
real good job with that no doubt i agree
the only thing i didn't like was
hammerhead i think they made him look
like a clown
yes but besides that
no doubt favorite console of all time
any generation
it's probably ps2
ps2 in the morning because it's the one
that you grinded the hardest for to get
with your own money
i think
there's there's some of that and also
it's just like when i think of the
library that's the first thing i think
of is just like an endless endless
stream of games that are all
really damn good absolutely
no doubt no doubt let's get into it last
week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken with the mpd sales
success of multi-player third-party
titles that are also day and date on
game pass do you think a single player
title can have a similar day-and-date
npd success in game pass the winner at
66 percent of the vote was yes game pass
games will still encourage paid sales
for single-player games
coming in at second at 23 of the vote
was the messy lords i don't care let's
deflect and talk about the playstation
plus subscriber numbers
it
nine is of the vote was no the service
will only cater to multiplayer or co-op
games to drive engagement group lord
solve your thoughts on this sir
i mean
it's just from the beginning this is one
of the things that from the beginning i
was like nah this can't be like
given the chance to play a game for
quote unquote free or whatever
you're gonna play it free right but the
fact of the matter is that no like
people will
gravitate to that if they want to and
play it that way
they'll purchase it if they want to it
doesn't deter people from not purchasing
the game no doubt hey you already see
mlb the show is the second best-selling
game of the year so far
here you
like baseball season it was coming and
we didn't know what was going to happen
and then boom shakalaka
party studio we love you sony thank you
so much
we didn't believe it it was true in the
beginning because it's like how could it
be right and it just it just keeps
proving itself correct so
let's get into this topic so uh lord
addict you're up do you want to greet
these superheroes there's not too many
that's too many okay it's not too many
let's just get you know uh we got kdk
five dollars for chat sorry i left you
out before cog i ran out of characters
i'm very happy to see you thank you well
happy lord's day i feel like i feel i
feel wanted now thank you and we have a
[ __ ] with the five dollar super chat i
just got a negative test result from the
clinic okay turns out the itch was to
play hades not chlamydia oh my god
wow what's going on
wow intense
thank you for sharing with that
where did that come out
he's like he's saving that one he would
save it that way so he wanted yeah he
wanted to spawn
that's that's something otherwise old
gamers are yes that's usually the thing
that's something
that's the will yeah for sure what else
we got and we got hard to find five
dollar super chat shout out to king for
being a creep getting intimately
involved with his games
[Laughter]
i'm in the same boat as y'all i wish i
had not traded in my collection of games
a copy of def jam fight for new york
would be nice yes yeah absolutely those
games
then we got face with the 20 super chat
thank you so much you guys ain't talking
about mpd this weekend king
well um as we know
mpd's has shown up and um
it's wonderful
[Laughter]
the switch
involved with mvd and as we're implied
well listen um switch is out head
selling consoles is doing what it's
supposed to do
uh
we we have a wonderful game leading the
way with the sword up
let's follow
month that you know the console is
something something something got to
work for them god bless
i mean it was nice like the month before
microsoft out earned them so less i'll
earn them they sold more and found i
felt so sorry for gene last week gene
comes in here with facts yeah yeah
hardcore facts and all king has to say
where the receipts do and everybody's
like yeah that's right with the receipts
though
i'm just really good at spinning it
sorry wow
what else we got so we got hard chinese
five dollars if you chat i don't see
abandon is one of the topics can you
have to talk about it
i don't see what else to talk about like
we clowned on abandon like three times
like yeah man there's not much else we
could say you guys are being finessed
and you're okay with being fine but what
it is is a lot of people don't know the
history of what is it blue balls
that's why we didn't have it as a topic
exactly so yeah it's like people don't
know the history of that studio and what
what's transpired and it just sucks that
other people that don't know that want
to support and go to these platforms and
put their money in and they don't have
any return off of it and it kind of
sucks so it's not something to like joke
about because people actually lost funds
in trying to show some form of support
and everybody wants to go out and
support right but then you're like oh
this up and coming they have a great
idea they're going to come out with this
and boom you got duped
so and not enough people go out and
expose them and then the next person
gets uh duped you know so it kind of
sucks we got it's a good point i've
never heard anyone like have a take like
that about that i think that's something
that's really worth considering people
like and like you know yeah no doubt
what else we got off we got mods gaming
tons of snapchats what's up
i must try to chicago pizza pie one day
no you ain't missing that no listen all
right so you're not missing anything
don't even let him try it
he he has to try because you know some
people like abundance right so if you do
though make sure that i'm with you so we
can go to a nice safe section so you can
buy your pizza
you don't want to just willy-nilly just
get out there and buy a pizza that's not
what you want to do
we're good we're all right cool let me
just why are you doing
in boston you eat chowder and lobster
this is true this is true not to be
beaten no doubt caught up there yes all
right cool you know t-sp ring merch uh
shout out to anonymous bought a classic
t i see you with the drip another
anonymous got the white i o pc with the
trip um
third anonymous
you got the long sleeves you know what
i'm saying
all right somebody put their name in
robert coming shout out he got the all
over print joggers no doubt the unity
line we got the joggers out there no
doubt
i'm wearing a different level of our
merch today cog is wearing his different
level i'm wearing my different weight
actually i have
there we go everybody's got the
merchandise
we got log nuts finest right there
salute to everybody we appreciate it
let's get into this topic i have a
question yes do you guys have uh the
flags available for purchase the flags
which ones which talk about the things
if you look pinned on the uh youtube
channel i mean right now on the live
chat we've got the teespring link for
all that stuff there was a nice sir much
appreciated and um yeah let's get into
this topic so lord attic man big one
hades
release
right now game pass sovereign's favorite
that is very upset with us
but um yeah what what are you feeling
and then let's get lord jake's uh
opinion in this one when she off
let let me mute my music okay oh
oh
here we go okay first off people who
came at me just because i said why do
you start with the smoke
the smoke is getting addressed first the
people that would sit there hey addict
what why do you like what
return why do you like hades more than
maternal
look it's not my fault that the game is
better it's just not my fault like
i get it like i know i don't get it you
guys are wrong like look hades like okay
i will i'm being a fraud when it came to
the perspective of hades i didn't play
it so i didn't know it i didn't i
haven't played a whole lot of roguelike
games and people told me hades is a huge
road like game it's like the the the
the entity that people look at when they
think about roguelike games i don't want
to go that far so
so i'm sitting here i'm playing return
and keep in mind just like someone's the
chat said people were saying i didn't
play return all people were saying i
didn't play much of return i got to the
fifth the fourth note the fifth the
fourth file that's almost the entire
game that's half that's more than
halfway through the game and then
they're like but addict why didn't you
like it it's such like a roguelike game
there's a difference when i play hades
and i die
i'm like man
let me let me take the stuff that i did
one more time let me take the stuff that
i got through that through that death
let me upgrade stuff get better weapons
and like go out there again and get this
done when i played return and about an
hour in and died i want to uninstall
that basket no tell me tell me about
like when you played and you got all
that stuff and it crashed and you lost
everything tell me about that tell me
about that though
when you i really wanted to return it
oh my god
look look i will say that there were
some glitches that may i'm not going to
bring up the you know the glitch thing
because it didn't happen to me much i
can't speak
to a lot of people let's talk about the
consumers but
all i'm saying is like what when you die
in haiti you know you could take the
keys get you new weapons when you when
you die in return you got that damn
pistol again right there's no changing
that like i don't to my knowledge
because you only got to the fourth biome
right maybe there's some kind of thing
that you could start with the weapon you
want like it but that to me that's a lot
like right every time i die in return
i'm being forced to use the pistol over
and over again
so it's just like but in hades you can
you can upgrade certain abilities every
run you can you can you can manually
choose what weapon you want to take out
there
then they give you another currency that
you could give to certain people to have
like like pretty much an artifact from
destiny to enhance you in some other way
and it's just like none of that is in
maternal guys
like stop it stop the capping so the the
the roll light is really light on that
part and and return it
return it and in hades they really lean
into the fact that you know it gives you
a lot of choice it gives you a lot of
reasons to explore the game and go
deeper into the game pause
is return got some
some um roguelike
features i i would say to a point right
but after playing hades i would say
very very light like very very light do
you feel that it's because of the
graphics of return
i feel like hades looks better than
eternal okay yeah i mean
art style-wise i mean it's apples and
oranges right but do you feel like well
you know the the fan base that is
clamoring there's only 560 000 of you
guys yeah and i don't believe that it's
only keep that number on deck to keep
that keep the sales numbers on deck for
return after you have to with these
dudes um because they always talk in
numbers right
so you applied the million versus this
is a banger this is a banger
so but i'm just saying like and i know
560 000 people didn't get at you so
let's let's take that number down to the
20 people that decided to talk all right
so
these individuals that came at you
because you purchased the game i saw you
play the game and you you really didn't
care for the game after what the game
did to you well
i i can't say return is a bad game it's
not a bad game it's just
i brought
no it's actually still installed on this
side see guys this blunt weapon object i
have called a ps5
y'all messy right now wow look like when
it comes to like return return is not a
bad game by any means it's a fun game
that you could play it's just i do feel
like they you know this was made after
hades right
and clearly that there's a lot of
aspects in hades that this game could
have really used like and if people go
sit there attic it's because it's a
playstation versus xbox thing how many
games on xbox have i completely went in
on this show like i'm so sick and tired
of you if you if you could have any type
of practice so you're implying any
playstation that there's a sensitivity
involved no no no there's definitely a
sensitivity such a sensitivity some of
you need help
moving on what i'm doing right now is
feeding him yes i don't know let's
because i know jake's top is limited i
gotta respect it so let's get jake's
opinion of hades and the fact that
launch on game pass or whatever or if
he's already played it already you know
what's your take on hades
hey also first don't feel rushed i'm
good i'm oh you're good
yeah come on
hades i haven't played a lot of and i'm
guilty of it and i should have played it
even when it was out on pc i had a
friend that was deep in it
so
yeah
i i haven't jumped into it a lot uh but
first impressions
it's like
everybody is really cool and smooth
my friend andrew explained it the best
way like that like just like the
presentation the characters like the
vibe
and and the writing like everybody's
like smooth and it's cool is
gameplay-wise though so far it's
probably going to be up my alley
everybody told me to play it because i'm
like a i'm a really big dead dead cells
fan yeah it's like not the same
that's the godfather yeah okay yeah
honestly so i'm i'm early but i'm into
it i'm into it no doubt no doubt
absolutely let's get my brother soft in
here um no let him go last night he's
got to go down
fast forward at the time i thought but
doc jake's with us we good go back to
you back to you hades is definitely like
what i like about hades is it's it's
like jake said like the game just like
it feels alive like you know it feels
like every character has a purpose
you know one thing i'm curious because
i'm not a huge unless it's like god of
war i don't really know a whole lot of
mythology right like is the sun a real
character or is that someone they just
made up they made them they made them up
yeah okay yeah because like i i like him
he's like he's a very likeable character
like when he dies it comes back like he
makes jokes that he's like yeah i
shouldn't have done that yeah
like i i i really enjoyed that
he's very handsome
i like when you talk to you when you
talk to your dad like he's like i don't
know why you keep trying yeah you're
kidding me
yeah
it's got that it's got that comedic
relief thing yes but it feels serious
like it feels like they're not trying to
be funny like like when you run into meg
uh that's uh you know one of the first
bosses she's always like and what's
funny is like it has that that that that
mental capacity that when you run into
her it's acknowledging that she has
served you before like she's killed you
multiple times you're right into it
she's like why do we keep doing this you
know you're not then when you finally
beat her and you get back to her she's
like
i guess we have to do this again like
she's not as extra after you actually
beat her the first time like
they got this hub world and what i
really enjoy about it and like when you
beat the first boss because when you die
you go back to this hub world everyone
does so when you beat the first boss
she's in that hub world when you die
again then you go up there and talk to
her she's like that was a fluke it's not
gonna happen again
so you get that personal interaction and
i heard the the conversations also
changed based on you know beating this
that that's pretty cool stuff i would
continue adding
yeah yeah you know what i like i just
like the the energy and the atmosphere
of this game like like and you can like
it and what's funny is like the game
isn't even like in terms of design it's
not even that serious it's like door oh
geez one door i like like
i like that you know not to be attacking
no no no all attention attacking return
though again this is the
impression sir when you walk no no i
have to breathe okay like look when you
walk into like on maternal you'd have to
find random stuff it's like rng on top
of rng but like in hades they're just
like yo this door you're getting this
this or you're getting this
so if you already got all if you don't
need no more keys because you've
unlocked every weapon then you just go
for the other door but it's like you
don't get that option in return
and i really like after really playing
this it makes me want to go back and
like really dive into dead cells like
because like when i play this game it's
like you know you can build your
character how you want to build like
when you see the little lightning thing
pop up you're like all right i need the
lightning dash yeah let me shut that
door right and then when you go through
that door and lightning dash isn't it
isn't a
choice you're like man that sucks but
what i like is after you beat the first
after you beat every boss they let you
go into like this pool thing and they
let you sell back some of your your your
moves so like for instance if i would
get like the uh the the goddess of
wisdoms dash or something and and that
you know zeus wasn't available because i
like the lightning one yeah when you
beat the first boss you're like yo i'm
gonna sell you this loved one or this
this wisdom dash and then i'm gonna try
to get the dash i want to get right so
like i just i appreciate the options i
appreciate the atmosphere i appreciate
the combat this is damn near a perfect
game
it really is like high praise not crazy
no doubt
i know you're waiting and i know i
didn't play this when it first came out
yeah and i have no i so i have a i have
a question
here we go what could was it robbed last
year during game of the year
never no it wasn't it wasn't like look
look as much as you like
that game
the game is amazing it is but i can't
realistically give
that game over last of us part two like
and then we we can't admit like was it
rob sophie was nominated for damn yeah
it wasn't every chat
it was wrong
that game took more more awards home
than almo i think almost anything else
there
but it didn't take home the most
important okay
okay
let's go
now first first and foremost just get it
um i never told you that it was a bad
game because i didn't play it right
right so
but you were you were raving about this
game you were you were
out there and i respect it right i
really do because that year god of war
won and spider-man didn't um i just
don't respect god of war completed the
spider-man um and that's just my opinion
of it spider-man is the real winner um
and you feel that like i feel red dead
was a real winner
but okay so um you feel like hades is a
real winner right so i'm playing hades
and i and i look over to wifey and i was
like yo cause i'm going back and forth
when i twitter rant then because you
felt that you want to fly close to the
sun
um yeah you are pretty close to the sun
for that kind of thought problem yeah
yeah he's obviously not twitter
yeah he went but he got burnt and he had
to get i didn't even hurt
hey listen look twitter guys twitter
guys you guys know exactly what happened
to him we're not gonna go there well
what's funny is what happened everybody
was agreeing what's up
you know what's crazy i i got the
numbers on top you know yeah
like live two different lives this week
on the same spectrum right now it's
always getting praise for his hades and
i'm getting slandered for mine continue
okay so
i i put i put the game in and i'm
playing it and i look over wifey and i'm
like because she's like because i'm
tweeting at the same time and uh she
said i said you know soft said this game
is better than the last of us too she
said what is he crazy
okay so for that um a person that
doesn't play games but visually she went
off the visuals but she also know the
emotional connection that i had with the
last of us too two different games not
even the same but as far as a roguelike
game and attic saying that it's pretty
much damn near perfect i can't put it
over dead cells for certain things that
dead cells does for me right
and um i really appreciate what dead
cells does um who told you about that
game too oh you did no i'm not saying
that you didn't thank you no didn't i
give you your your roses you did i just
wanted your face
and i purchased every dlc that came down
the pipe
for that game
right so that's this is it's no fluke
now hades what attic alluded to and what
he spoke about is the awareness that the
game has the game is totally aware of
everything that you've done i've died in
lava and i came out the the the blood
pit and i'm talking to the dude when i
first come out and he's like yeah
running around alive
like i'm like wow bro and sometimes
he'll give you like little clips of how
not to die at that point obviously you
just don't step in fire for that
incident but like when i got killed by
like uh like a hydra or whatever their
name is like medusa whatever yeah yeah
like he's like yeah yeah she's a problem
like i could be like
like attic loves the zeus weapon
um so my son is playing at the same time
i'm playing it right and he hates the
way i play the game
i spam my super button the y button i
spam the hell out of it right he's
that's not how you're supposed to play
it like like he's literally getting
frustrated with me i said why are you
upset because i'm actually clearing
boards without taking any damage yeah
all right so i had to lose power
don't take damage long distance fighting
he doesn't know about that he wants to
get him in squabbles this is all this is
but this is an upgraded super right this
is not okay no well even from the
beginning because you have to from the
beginning when you do it it you lose it
until you until you knock it off of that
opponent again right but i don't know
that no no no no he's talking about why
you talking right i'm talking about why
all you talk about the superstar okay
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that little chase that b is strong
though yeah it's gonna get the right
thing it's true but
see he'll look at attic and be like i
love how he plays and he's like daddy i
don't like how you play
[Laughter]
tell addict to send you some food all
right get out of here
so
i'm looking i'm thinking
i know sovereign's thought process yeah
artistically the game is impeccable
sound choice wise in every room the mood
sets perfectly
right
um and little kills because we come from
a 2d world me and sovereign is a really
different beast
when everybody was running the 3d we
were in saturn talking about the 2d
that this thing was right so we still
champion the 16-bit the 32-bit 2d games
uh and artistic value that these artists
do bring to this space so i think that's
where hades lives at haiti lives in this
artistic rich history everybody loves
greek mythology
and then to get voice acting
in a way and then it tells you a story
in a row like like you wake up in the
middle of the night do you want to rest
in bed and then you can go around and
find out why you're set on this journey
what happened who wrong who so we all
know in greek mythology is about lies
betrayal and deceit yeah and we're
finding out what's going on
you will get invested in this game in a
different manner opposed to any
roguelike that i've played and they
interweave that into
the the core
gameplay so we all we all know that the
gods like to interfere right and and
they're interfering in such a way with a
child that haiti doesn't want them to
talk to those family members right so
these family members because he knows
what they're about and he's like you
don't you don't mess with them and he's
talking to his wife about you know these
people how they interfering with their
kid and then they do what hades doesn't
want them to do yeah and the kid is
doing all the stuff and you got to pay
for construction of the house i think
this game
it's all like gaming ahead of me
no no no where you talking the way you
the way you blow me
it's not i don't remember this stuff
it's not because when you put it i did a
whole podcast i know
i
yeah the last of us to
approach
conversations that are current yeah real
quick right current conversations that
are people developers and and people are
afraid to talk about and that's the
reason why it got game of the year for
me it was a segment of the population
that doesn't have a voice right that got
a voice through this game and it made
people uncomfortable this game doesn't
make me uncomfortable in the least
right so it's nothing that you're afraid
to approach at all it's a fun game
it's it's actually a great game and it's
probably
going to be
a number one interactive game on game
pass for a very long time for as long as
it gets there and i know for a fact once
that game says it pops up that it's
going to leave i know people are going
to purchase it because i purchased it
off the rip off of respect for sovereign
right then and there i said let me
purchase this game right off the rip
it's really good let's be like
it's crazy
that this kind of caliber game yeah that
hasn't been on playstation and xbox all
this time
comes into the xbox ecosystem on gamepad
yeah
let me let's be real there's a lot of
people that have both consoles yeah
especially the ps4 and the uh the ps4
and the xbox one like so now when hades
drops on on these consoles people's like
yeah i'm getting that on game pass
i'm not even playing that on playstation
so you get this kind of mentality with
multiple games people are going to start
playing more games on xbox because
they're used to playing on xbox yeah
we'll get to it i want to get solved
because he's been waiting
um sir so you had some comments on
twitter i did i got i got my first taste
of like king level smoke yeah i don't i
don't go in all the way like i can't do
it because listen even even with the
little wink winks i got two like two
people that were like why are you hating
on other people's gay and i'm like
oh jesus christ
i i can't do what king does people king
throws out grenades and he just he wants
it all back yeah
you're still commenting on that 80s
poster yes
you know how i know when when a tweet
gets big when i see people starting to
tweet me in spanish
you transcended yeah yeah you start
crossing over to different languages
some french dudes or whatever was on i
just like wow
clarity lord jake uh saab's tweet
oh that was it the e the impressions had
a hundred thousand yeah a hundred
thousand he says i just want to give a
big shout out to all you frauds that
should have played hades last year but i
digress enjoy your 2021 game of the year
so that set up a firestorm and saw the
king going at it but
now that you know why don't you read
mine
oh that's super small yeah
we'll i'll get to in a minute a second
but oh yeah like the thing is so i'm
like now that everyone is experiencing
what you experienced already like what
are your thoughts about it now that
everybody's kind of like loving this
game [ __ ] i know
you know i'm excited everybody's playing
that i'm excited that people and it's
one of those games like it's
i forgot who it was in my in my chat
that was like i don't play those type of
games but after all the discourse i'm
gonna get it and then the answer i got
was like oh my god
oh my god and it's like it and it it has
that sort of effect so
going back to
what last year why i felt this was my
game of the year over the last of us yes
i love the last of us too for the most
part for the most part right we can and
i had discussions about certain things
about the story that
um and it's not the things that most
people think about right
it's when you think about the last of us
too in terms of production value in
terms of
in terms of story like in terms of
everything around that game that makes
it
what it is
it still isn't really
why we
came to games to begin with right okay
right
when i look at a small game like that
and i and i also talk about like a dead
cells i'll talk about a couple of years
ago when my game of the year was celeste
right right
for me when i when i start to compare
those smaller games to the bigger games
i think about what are the core things
that made me fall in love with gaming
right
and it is that idea of going into a game
and the gameplay being so addictive that
no matter how many times you lose
one more time
i want one more time and the game
facilitates that right with with uh
return you look at return it has some of
those gameplay aspects the problem
returner is that if you go in for a run
that's an hour long which in a rogue
like doesn't really happen
and you lose at that point yeah it
throws you right back in but the sense
of loss
is totally different than what you
experienced in your typical roguelike
type of game reiterating uh addict's
incendiary tweet
that i have to read this
again lord jake another
firestorm addict said after playing
after playing hades totally can see why
people that played it was saying return
is a bad game in terms of roguelite
hades destroys fraternal hell it's the
most fun i've had on xbox in a while
besides maybe the halo infinite beta the
game is amazing can't stop playing it
that was the other tweet that was um
dare you like something
god forbid
i can't i can't say he play a victim now
he threw destroys with turtle in that
tweet so i can't get him with this
victim yeah yeah is that
what he was doing letters yeah
yes but
see look i wanted to make sure when
people read that oh yeah you know the
energy i'm saying yes
and imagine me saying hey these destroys
were eternal i wanted people to read
them be like hades destroys fraternal
yeah
you don't understand why people are
coming at you
so for me so for me that core idea of a
game that keeps me coming back for more
and keeps me engaged in that way and
then when you add the the layer of story
that it integrates into the gameplay
mechanic yeah when you add the
characters when you add the music when
you add the voice acting i was like wow
i forgot what i forgot what games i
chose celeste over that year um but it
was the same things like celeste felt
like a perfect platform yeah like there
was nothing wrong with that game
platforming wise the thing that it set
out to do it did damn near perfectly
yeah and that's why i felt for me hades
was the game of the year over last of us
because the last of us i sat there and
cried multiple times during that game my
wife looked at me like i was a fool
[Laughter]
and
but there were things about it where
it's a masterpiece to me but it's a
flawed masterpiece i look at hades and
hades feels like like addicts said damn
near a perfect game
at doing what it sets out to do i got
like 10 hours in it and i still haven't
found like anything that like i would
change
and that's the thing so for me that was
it right so my excitement because i
remember last year
keep in mind i'm hard on games yeah
you're very yeah you're very critical
you're very crazy and last year i think
i i think my time you know when you
introduced us
before the podcast every every podcast i
think for like two months straight it
was like
hey these hades
and so
and the thing about it another thing
that bothered me last year about how it
went down was yeah
sometimes i get mad at at sort of the
media and how they address certain
things and then when it comes to talking
about you know game of the year though
those things get pushed under the rock
right there was a lot of talk about the
culture at naughty dog the crunch all
this stuff people were going crazy
talking about this oh my god i cannot
believe it
end of the year comes game of the year
like anatomy i'm like
um you know
it's just one of those things like when
you talk about a product in its entirety
you make it seem like you're going to
take a stand on it right
and not you know whatever
but at the end of the day nobody took a
stand on it right and then when you look
at hades it was the complete opposite
where it was a game that essentially
became as great as it was
because of the input from fans right
so that that to me is why when i compare
like a giant like a naughty dog game to
something like this
it just shines that much brighter for me
so
still my game of the year that's it
i'll keep it quick because you guys
pretty much said every point i was gonna
say i mean look i mean i am definitely
for alert on me because you know i i had
it on switch and i'm just like man once
i knew it was coming to xbox i'm like i
want those achievements jake i want you
know what i'm saying like
how did that it's
i would not have big up that game on the
switch if it ran like trash
yeah i get that but
look i i i play the switch probably more
than anyone here now
because like zelda and default
it's like at the same time
i ain't buying hades on the switch like
it's not happening
why why
look at it it's the most switch ass game
there is exactly well it could switch
its ass straight out language
language is the sundance
you look at that game and it doesn't
make sense to be like i refuse to buy
this game i don't know why i don't why
don't buy it on the switch but anyway
the only games i bought on the switch is
is nintendo games yeah
third parties don't exist to you on the
switch we get all right so like i was
saying back to my point um yeah like at
the end of the day like you know the
game coming to the xbox platform coming
to playstation this whole audience that
never you know would be introduced to it
and now introduced to it it was it was
really cool and i have to admit like
like king said it best you know i'm not
i'm be real i'm not really a roguelike
guy that's not my thing but the way it's
woven into the lore and the narrative
and then where they got me is i am greek
mythos guy like i love that zeus hades
all that like that's me so you got that
the art style is beautiful you know what
i'm saying the music is great that it's
voice acting i like the narrator voice
acting and like alex said the humor like
while the narrator is saying these
really dark tone things you know your
man is snapping back at it you know
after that raiders so to speak so it's a
good game it's a good game and
a good get for game pass like absolutely
good game for game match it made it so
good that i was like yo i would like
saint monica to make a game about this
dude
like that god of war style because like
that's how good of a character they made
this because that's why i asked like
like he was so well done yeah i was like
does this dude exist to me
yeah yeah
the crazy thing is these guys don't
really do sequels yeah and it it's one
of those things where i'm sure they're
looking like damn is this on the table
now yeah like if they say that right
probably some good dlc yeah we got to
see but that's all like you know what we
got curse uh from um
the dead god from right right right
yeah so and that's a totally different
game and how it plays so yeah you never
know no no no doubt no doubt so that's
what i got on that's move on real quick
um
how many we got
to move on uh we have smitty smith yeah
yeah no we got mods then we got donald
taco hold on five dollar super chat i've
been playing hades on series x but i
still feel it's better playing on the
switch with the native portable option
it just feels right absolutely 520p it
doesn't feel right
sir stop you're gonna hurt your eyes
you're gonna need glasses
[Laughter]
all right let's go now that's super
[Applause]
you every five seconds to up the
difficulty while hades makes you feel
more powerful with each run but your
skill but your skill is why you lose
then we have raiden blade five pound
super chat the god thunder sword has
arrived what's good fellas i'm so loving
game pass i play more games than i would
let's go x-box
salute to you thanks smitty smith five
dollars a chat lord sovereign thank you
brother for championing hades that game
is fantastic past the book of acts
hey guys with the recent pc mod and the
ascent where you can go into the world
should uh neon giant release the camera
angle as a patch it's funny because i
thought i've always talked about this
this is a game if you turn that camera
angle around and turn it into a
quote-unquote playstation game right
wow
wow wow wow and it's it's just about
it's what people consider to be triple a
right quote unquote triple a the
production value is there but the camera
angle is going to immediately turn
certain people off right it just went up
then we got donna taco 5 super chat
hades was the real game of the year 2020
and it wasn't even close a near perfect
game also it won every other big game of
the year award besides the game award
well obviously what i was saying it's
obvious it was robbed okay obviously the
people that mattered voted
you got everything i'm gonna answer that
just didn't get the nachos with your
cheese so sorry buddy you got everything
else buddy we take home the prize there
we go
boris five dollar super chat well king
sounds like a man that's stuck between i
love and i really like hades has him and
his feelings for real man
she's in the whole time yeah
you're very like you know what you know
what it is
meg killed him a couple of times so he
was done i say this right you say i love
and i like just get both yeah there
there you go that's it what else you got
lucious augustus 5 chad the last of us
two is a great movie but not a great
game saab is right if we're going to
celebrate video games in game of the
year give it up to games that
personified games wait wait wait a
second you're gonna say that you wasn't
playing again i don't know what game you
were playing sir but then you have to go
from point a to point b so your
controller you left your controller on
the floor and they did
ten dollars in the chat slav is my guy
this era of story-driven games tend to
have average to good gameplay besides
rare occasions
indeed nintendo are the only ones
pushing amazing game players to priority
which it should be
cool i will say this about the last of
us too though it has an amazing game
yeah the game play
come on
it really updates
their absolute frauds when sony showed
that screen and she ran through ellie
ran through and she grabbed that bottle
hit the dude in the face slid behind the
thing shoot the ball
he was like there's no way that's going
to happen if they actually did it you
was like if they had it
are we confident that we said that or
you said that
listen everybody was saying that there's
no way that was going to happen and then
when they actually do it you're not
going to give them praise and then the
story just did watch what would you
watch a level watch watch a video of
high level gameplay in in last of us two
it's kind of it's it feels like a genre
crazy yeah
um then we got shroom kingdom two dollar
super chat keep that lizard in the
bushes yes
yes yes let's just stay in the bushes
around a little bit we're good
all right
are we caught up yes sir all right
quickly solve this is you we got uh two
things id at xbox and what's up with
gays comes up
uh okay so first off we had an idea at
xbox show i think this was past week um
yeah again it was the id at xbox slash
twitch format so again i wasn't too
happy with the format just because i
just rather get all my announcements up
front i like this cadence of give me the
announcements i do like to see
the uh the developers get their their
shine i really do like that i just think
that you take away from it when you sort
of put it right into the middle of the
show as opposed to putting it off to the
side afterwards and
you allow people to choose whether they
want to engage or not because what
happens is that any announcements that
you have after these sort of long
segments where they're talking to the
devs and you're showing extended
gameplay anybody who's disinterested is
going to walk away right that's true and
and probably miss some cool
announcements at the end so i like the
fact that they're getting a shine i'm
not a big fan of the format okay so um
of the stuff that they talked about that
was really interesting to me
um ali ali world looks fantastic
i love skateboarding games i played ali
ali one and two on the vita i want to
meet ali ollie
fantastic game so the fact that they're
expanding the world out it it seems
really cool um so i'm excited for ali
right they said 4k 120. 120. yeah
yeah
um
something's going on chad says shut off
you're good yeah i'm good the thing is
my headset keeps connecting and this is
not gonna go now you're good
um and then beyond that um
something that we we went and to see at
e3 maybe two years or three years ago
now evil genius too oh yeah yeah you're
an addict yes yes
so that that was cool to finally see
that sort of coming out on on the
consoles because i know i went to pc
first and whatnot so it's cool to see
that and for me i'm a big stealth guy um
origami too uh the first origami uh
y'all stealth tattoo guys yes attention
guys
guys is it a question
because i think this one is
gonna take so long for this game to come
like yeah
to come out yeah
you lose today
no i'm not
i'll continue so that and so again
origami too i love stealth and i i just
the fact they got the opportunity to
expand on what they did in the first one
because the first one was a little rough
around the edges but yeah again we
didn't we haven't had that tension fixed
yes
i really enjoy that and again for the 2d
platformer like love in me
hey on drive look kind of fantastic
so i'm excited about that but again uh i
thought what they showed was very cool
i'm just not a fan of the format no
doubt and quickly before i pass it to
jake um gamescom 2021 announcements yes
i think paris is going to be harrison
paris lilly is going to be co-hosting
with uh kate yeager yes uh
and this is going to be kind of in the
lead up to games.com proper right it's
kind of in the days leading up to it um
yeah and it's exciting because we
gamescom is usually the place where you
get sort of expanded looks at things
that they already talked about at e3
right
so but again because of the way of the
world right now that may not necessarily
remain the same so we could i would love
to get expanded looks at everything else
that's coming out this year and that'd
be great i would love to get a halo
release date that would be fantastic
um
i don't want to see any more of forza
i'm good i'm just i'm gonna see more
yeah
we've seen enough fours out here yeah i
don't want to see that um
but i'm excited for it everything else
though you know there could be some cool
announcements you know maybe maybe you
know all these sort of uh these rumored
acquisitions maybe could get brought up
or something like that so i'm just
excited for what it could be okay no
doubt let's get lord jake in man so
first id at xbox did you get a chance to
see it any standouts for you and then
all obviously the gamescom 2021
announcement for xbox
yeah saab said pretty much everything
right now like same exact things it was
that uh origami definitely uh and then
there was like a game about uh taking
pictures of dogs
i need dumb little things like that
sometimes you know like untitled goose
game just like those loops
that are just nice little digestible
things that you just kind of like an
appetizer game uh so i'll take that that
was nice and in the gamescom news
i think the paris thing is like the
coolest thing in the world yeah
absolutely
there's nothing better than just seeing
good people that we know and we work
with and around yes do more
and be exposed to even more people yes
and like who deserves it facts and the
good the good thing about you know the
pandemic is it gives people more of an
opportunity to do stuff they wouldn't
normally be able to do like you know
because everything's so digital it's
easier to set these kind of projects up
than it was
when you know everything was so open no
doubt now let me ask you lord jake this
and reference to the games because this
is a big discussion i'm about to ask you
on iop as far as halo infinite right and
you know we know we're getting close
hopefully you know this year with maybe
getting a release date do you think it
happens there do you think
it halo is big enough to kind of do its
own announcement separate from gamescom
because the the the controversy on our
healthy
is you know they should kind of stay
away me and attic feel they should kind
of stay away from call of duty's release
date whereas solving kingdom like look
it's free to play halo's being pop you
know received well the the flight you
know
we don't care about what c or d doing
like pretty much yeah so pretty much
we're right there
so we want to get your thoughts as far
as halo infinite gamescom announcement
and your your whole vibe with that
i think
i don't know i'd like them and i feel
like they would just do their own thing
and announce it right now like one more
good
i mean like we haven't really seen
single player since
the original tease where a lot of people
weren't super pleased with it so
right yeah except for like uh just that
trailer yeah yeah
so i'm curious to see if they can
sell us more of that like the the
party that you're gonna buy right um so
i feel like they would just do their own
whole thing where they show off a little
more of that and they
announce it in terms of timing
it's weird right because
we're getting another call of duty and
now we know like the leak says call of
duty vanguard um
there's
in our bubble in our world i feel like
there's less enthusiasm it's like some
people are starting to be like all right
call of duty like maybe you should have
taken a year off
world war ii again
like we're having these conversations
but
then the greater gaming community yes
they're just gonna buy it facts they're
gonna buy it every year no matter what
it's like a madden it's like a fifa yeah
or whatever the majority of people who
play call of duty don't even know who
makes call of
duty yeah
so i so i wonder where
halo can kind of do its own thing i feel
like it can cut out a different
carve a different thing but then for
halo 2 there's also a huge
casual audience too yeah they are going
to have to you know like because i have
i have friends and family that
are those bros that they only play call
of duty and they also were like oh i
love halo i grew up playing halo too so
there is that like line that they have
to walk i that is not a tricky i feel
like i feel like halo has been in such a
tricky spot
every single point where it's like all
this pressure on it from from xbox
series x launch
to
the people not thinking it looked so hot
to them going back to leadership changes
to now this and then timing when they're
actually going to put it out and then
there was like a whole pandemic like
there's a million things kind of against
halo and you can't just help but root
for it because it's
yeah
at this point it's the underdog at this
point
yeah because you got battlefield showing
their uh single-player story now it
looks ridiculous it looks absolutely
insane so you got to figure out where
you're going to place halo in between
these juggernauts right out there and at
the same time you got to still continue
to look at apex which is putting out
their seasons you got to look at
overwatch and you got to look at all
these other stuff where it's going to
yeah exactly especially fortnite
fortnite is a beast within itself so
you're placing uh halo in this
free-to-play world where there are
actually beasts and juggernauts living
in that space and then you're talking
about the the single-player aspect of
the game like what you said that the one
that they're gonna buy um and you
haven't shown anything since you know
you really had the craig incident so
craig incident of 2020 exactly because
you know it's like he said you're in a
space they would have loved to have
released that game back then and let
that game grow but now you're in a space
now where one you have to hit the mark
right two you can't have no craigs right
so
what happens now where are they at now
so yeah i feel you guys
i i tend to agree with what you're
saying when it comes to premise and
thought process but i feel that they're
in such a position where they have no
other choice but to push forward and
believe in their product so that's where
my thought process comes in with the
sovereign you know brute force through
whatever happens happens opposed to
ducking and dodging and moving because
already and that's that's that believe
in your product that's absolutely and if
if the game is for sure ready on the
15th
go you need to hit that game you just
have to you have to well let me let me
ask this is going to be really for attic
too but i want to ask you jake's opinion
on it
so according like based on what you said
jake like they don't have today like
halo could technically
343 can technically do their own
little showcase for when they want to
announce it separate from gamescom right
so my question to you is
do you feel if it's not if it's
definitely not announce the release date
for halo at gamescom
are you concerned
that the game might not come out this
year
oh i you know what
at this point with with halo and like
what addict said how it's like kind of
like the underdog now at this point
i think they can still just take as long
as they need okay they got some really
good buzz from the infinite yes uh thing
or what was that a beta
technical flight whatever yeah technical
flight that sounds like when i go on an
airplane
so
at this point like they have that buzz
they can let that you know
there is something to be said about
games that come out after that holiday
season dump
there's always a good spot for another
game to shine it used to be more so when
releases were less widespread and more
staggered but
i don't know if they if they announce a
delay i'm not going to laugh i'm going
to say all right
no but that's not a delay
but what i meant to say is like are you
concerned if gamescom the show ends
paris eight get off the stage
we don't have no release date for halo
are you concerned or you're not
concerned like you're not worried about
they can still do it on a separate thing
yeah okay
that's what i
i had to ask that question for you
because i know how you feel about
release dates and when you don't see
them so first indies the indie show you
know did you see anything there that
caught your interest and then second
gamescom and the whole halo infinite
thing so i did not watch the andy show
so um
you know that is that that is that
that's your analysis
when it comes to
halo like
for some reason
i'm convinced like 80 90 percent sure
it's coming out this year wait a minute
but you because
it was all over horizon forbidden west
that's because horizon's been quiet they
don't talk about horizon they don't
bring up around them
they they do entire they do entire
gameplay shows and then and then when
people ask oh we're working on it we're
working on it right like people ask phil
spencer and he's like we got the date
down we just don't know what
he didn't say that
he seems way more confident that that's
coming out this is their confidence
send me your knees
no
what's this there will love
there's a great i would say
80 90 chance it comes out this year i
feel like
they are waiting for release dates on
stuff they want to make sure that you
know they don't the thing is is like
phil spencer knows it could come out
this year he knows it is to me there's
multiple variables he wants to make sure
that they say the right release date
he don't want to throw it out oh it
comes out in october november december
and then and then have to push it back
even a week you don't want none of that
bad public
uh publicity he he wants when he says
that game's coming out that day that
game comes out that day
and then plus i think you know they are
concerned maybe not concerned but they
are like okay you know call of duty
doesn't have a release date you know we
want to be able to navigate these c's
and as much as people don't want to
admit it like
halo hasn't been in the best place in
the few years uh installments but it's
not been in the worst either
and you know they still got to compete
with the like look like you got to give
it time to breathe from call of duty you
just got to like sure
my thing with them is do what's best for
halo not what's best for microsoft's ego
i feel that well if if microsoft's like
yo we could release this the day of call
of duty no you can't
don't listen to that
i'll win that one don't listen to that
man did you get a chance to see the id
at xbox show yes yes to my dismay um
okay so now that we know that twitch is
fitting the bill right okay so microsoft
was like okay we want to show id at xbox
right in in all our glory and we want to
show developers and stuff like that and
we also want to show content creators uh
because that's a way of highlighting
different content creators to give them
a platform that they won't normally have
and this is great right you know you
have twitch streamers and stuff like
that yeah that actually get a chance to
talk to the developers that they love
that's a good format right and in
premise it works but for us
news hungry
animals that
don't care to hear about thomas
backstory with how he did this and you
know yeah yeah we don't care about that
real quick we just want the games real
quick like you know what i like about
them getting like you know uh
influencers such as like pair so
literally on that stage because like i
feel like people like pair slowly like
in that kind of bracket they can we
could we we can relate to them better
being content creators so like
like when people like paris literally
talk like what i would just say is like
when people like paris lilly talk like
you can see like he's a gamer and not
like necessarily someone out there
that's just a host well like because
these twitch dudes are gamers they
literally
i get this part right here and i get
that but sometimes it's different than
than commentary and playing a game than
it is hosting an event yeah but see okay
but all right so i understand what's
exactly what you're saying the the
format i don't agree with the format of
the twitch format right like for me for
my consumption taste um i'm in more
aligned with sovereign give me the list
of how i was going to go down and if i
want to tune in or i can you know go
through the thumbnails and see stuff i
could do that or just put the games out
and then i can look at them and then if
i want to see uh the in-depth with the
developer on any game i can watch that
and that well how that has to happen is
that the show has to be completed first
for them to do it right um
it's good in premise and execution they
have to tweak some stuff right and
that'll happen but the games that they
did show 14 games has gone into game
pass another amazing cool for game pass
which is absolutely nuts ali ali world
origami 2 uh the the the stealth boss
game these these games is their games in
there that slayer don't forget the last
time we saw uh this stuff we saw a
death's door and from what people are
telling me
that game is almost game of the year
type of games
yeah i will get it in game pass when
phil says
says it's cool
yes yes
i have too much so when it shows up in
the game pass shout out i pay game pass
every month so if you want to change me
for for using what i'm paying for you're
crazy right
but i'm gonna wait to it show up with my
boxes at anyway so
we we have games that's coming 14 new
games i love
that aspect of when they start
any convention off with microsoft
these games is for a game pass right
they tell you right off the rip right 14
games is coming and you're like wow you
look at the show differently now you're
not looking at it with your wallet
you're looking at it with okay what
interests me what's what can i check off
oh i'll be on the lookout for this when
it comes out so
those games and stuff look good as far
as the power of solidity and the gamecom
stuff yeah i was really pleased with
that because
the last show that he headlined was
really done well right yeah right and i
thought that okay the in-depth the deep
dive
that's stuff
when they tell you ahead of time what
it's going to die right done well and he
is such an energetic uh eloquent
speaking great host that uh
talks to all of us content creators be
it people of color be it of uh you know
of people not of color it's
he's talking to us because he comes from
us right right so we identify with him a
little bit more so we are definitely
going to tune in i know
you know um so he's a very personable
dude and i'm going to definitely support
but i know i'm going to get a good show
i know he's going to give 110 like the
last show yeah so um i'm looking forward
to that and do i i think they're going
to give a date no i don't think so i
think halo is strong enough for it to
stand on its own merits that they're
going to use that show to talk about
other stuff that they need the light on
i think halo has enough of a light it
can do its own skin no doubt not for
what you're saying look i agree with a
lot of you guys um most of the games you
guys already stole from the id and xbox
thing i'll make it quick i agree with
solve and king in the sense that you
know look whatever deals that xbox has
with twitch you know what i'm saying we
get it but i do feel the format is too
long if it's three to four hours
you know you got it that's the reason i
didn't watch it yeah it could you gotta
condense it you know and then honestly
that's the reason why we didn't stream
it because last time we were there for
three hours that was coming
crazy that's kind of crazy so we was
like id xbox twitch when we see that
might catch three cats oh
but at the end of the day my thing is
you know
the games that were shown obviously jake
what you said ali ali looks amazing the
art style cell shaded look real cool the
customization the fire you know what i'm
saying shout out to maddie plays he's
super hyped from defining dude when you
talk talking to him about it bro that's
the game for you right there i already
see you know what i mean so you got that
um i thought inked looked very
interesting very cool art style then
they got real darks off like a fourth
wall the artist drawing on the page
killing characters throwing them in
furnaces that's the rpg right i don't
know what it is yeah it's it's an rpg
and and remember the game um what was
that comics something um from comic zone
comic zone yeah you don't remember how
these you draw yeah when you go to the
next panel
yeah this dude is yes it's dark it got
dark quick it went from qcqc to dark so
that's that um the veil was interesting
it was like a game where again you use
your senses and salute to the devil
forgot his name but you know it's
basically you're playing as from the
perspective as if you're blind and yes
you have to hear stuff so i want to see
how they execute with that and you
already said that origami you already
know i'm attention boy you like ted's
you all day so anything that's the
spiritual successor attention with true
stuff because we ain't got enough
stealth games man i'ma always die on the
stealth game sword that's my joint and
the last thing i say with that on the
twitch joint
sarah bond interview was very important
right like she dropped a lot of facts
there and showing xbox's commitment to
indie game developers and showing how
they're getting them the tools to get
them the services and then i have them
on the storefront if they're in a game
package oh i'm sure after that fiasco
will place they got they're like yo we
gotta jump in there to me that was this
is the largest thing xbox yeah that was
a different xbox yes they doing all
right so the differences that you're
seeing now sony always used to
capitalize on xbox mistakes right always
100 and that was that was that that was
that's what made you feel good about the
platform right you know you knew it was
a clap back everybody like clap back
everybody like that smoke but right now
that was a killer like that was really a
killer and
this stuff
they're doing they're capitalizing
capitalizing smart delivery we've seen
the capitalization you saw as far as the
storage thing the cat they oh they go
through their dog let me let me tell you
something that really happened so my boy
um got his uh his playstation right
right he put in his ssd right so he
actually he wanted me to be there to
film it right just in case something
goes wrong he had to send the film the
song right so i'm filming it while he's
doing it so he puts it in nothing
nothing happened his joint work it's
really it's cool so he's playing ratchet
and clank right and he wants to go to
spider-man right so he's like yeah yeah
did you beat this boss or whatever
whatever and i'm like yeah yeah he said
well huh cause i'm stuck here so he goes
and he gets out goes to the menu put
some spiderman we have to wait for
spiderman to boot up play spiderman and
he comes over to my house right right
i'm playing hades and then i switch off
to
dragon quest shout out to drag quest
finish my dragon question absolutely all
right finish that oh shout out so the
question is did you finish dragon quest
or did you bg finish dragon quest
did you beat dragon quest or did you
beat beat dragon quest there's two
differences
i was going to ask you a question about
the ending but anyway because you got to
go back into the game too to do the
ceremony so um i i i jumped that and
then we jumped back to hey uh hades
right he doesn't have a series x oh this
is the the quick result he said
yo
what the hell did you just do
and i said oh oh that's quick resume
mm-hmm
he said wait a second wait a second how
many games you can do that with mm-hmm
so i showed him the list and he was like
wait you can jump at any point in time
to these games from here to there like
that yeah i said yeah that's that's the
ssd and that's the quick resume that's
the varsity architecture shout out
the cleanest bed in the game
so
until you see it right
he he automatically started looking for
series s or x i said you ain't gonna
find right so you started looking for s
until you see it it doesn't hit and i
had to say that because i would i would
have got off the show today without
saying it but some he saw it right there
it was just like a revelation like
something really went off and it's
and he didn't understand what it was
until they actually said so it's
something magnificent that happened in
my house this week no i just kind of
[ __ ] or really respect i mean like i
said my final point was just that like
you said with the capitalizing my
mistakes or whatever but
she made a good point in just talking
about engagement and how
you know they're getting like eight
times more engagement and
discoverability when the indies are are
being put in the platform and salute to
them because we've seen you know let's
be real what the start of the
playstation 4 generation playstation was
very in front with indies you know i'm
saying very they did a very good job
whereas xbox everybody's like yo what's
going on the idx xbox program wasn't
started yet and i believe at the time
soft there was a disparity where xbox
had to fix where indies were literally
complaining complaining yeah it was the
same the playstation issue that they
kind of have
right right right it was in reverse
right so to see them transform this
whole thing around and then have a
showcase like that is it's very
impressive and with the gamescom thing
obviously shout out to lord paris who
was in here earlier great to see him get
another opportunity shout out to kate
that's gonna be fantastic i'm looking
forward to it i don't think there's
gonna be like major
future stuff if you're coming in looking
for like yo i'm gonna see all this
future stuff i don't think it's that i
think it's what's coming out 2021 you
know that kind of thing and then you
know i'll be honest jake i want i want
the halo infinite really stay i don't
know
i don't know what's going to happen but
i would like i do kind of want it i kind
of want it to know and um you know the
rumors are out here because right now
obviously uh call of duty got leaked
right vanguard we know the names on
lordsgamer.net we put that out there but
um you know it got is out there and then
we're hearing the rumors of gta what is
it um remastered november 11th so the
rumors right now
from what we hear
is vanguard
november 5th jake is dancing
november 5th and we're here in gta 11th
and we know the anniversary of halo is
is the 15th which is my birthday which i
would love for them to do
so yeah i mean
i think it's it could be set up really
nicely for them and you get get at it
and you have forza in there as well and
four city of course i think they need to
pop that off in october i'm gonna be
real with you
i think you want to get ahead of me i
think i think you know consider november
like what's what i'm looking for
consider it
uh like a nuclear zone from fallout stay
away from this month mike i will say
this though i will say this i think no
you know i'm with you as far as
respected card
um my only thing i think with now we i
thought cod would be later right but now
with gta at 11th we know that
claude cannot
car got to be shook a gta
like car can't play and be like yo we're
coming out
carl's not going to be shipped
[Music]
that's been remade like three times yeah
i think if it was a main release if it
was like a main rockstar release every
mountains would move but with like a
re-release of something that's earned no
it's a re-re-release right but guess
what get this mountains have moved
because the rumor is that it's moving to
november
so so all this talk the rumor is is
literally again it's a rumor but it's
suggesting that it may stay away from it
and if that's the case and you got fifth
then when when's forza what's up
11th gta in here that's a lot of stuff
right that's all i'm saying october
microsoft october that would be cool i'm
actually cool with november yeah i've
actually quoted them
i want the halo anniversary november
15th let's go with that i feel like my
brother i'd rather go this
rather
way
i'd rather microsoft launch after the
day battlefield comes out then compete
with everything in
november like battlefield it should have
been in game pass
but i can't imagine yeah
but look that that's what i got on it
it'll be fun yeah that would be some
petty stuff you didn't let that come on
game pass we bout to release halo on
that date
gabe industry does not work on that type
of reactionary time
also
let's just speed through if you don't
mind uh yes i got no problem yeah so
look let's get very small very quick um
yeah so possible premium version i don't
know
on the way you know would you mind if i
go first i mean let me just set it up
for him um
that's why i asked for your permission
this is the last joint look sonny sony
funimation global group completes the
acquisition of crunchyroll from t in a
massive deal worth 1.175
billion
sony pictures entertainment and at t
announced the acquisition of a tnt's
crunchyroll and in a business through
funimation global group llc crunchyroll
is the premiere right attic anime direct
to consumer service with 5 million
subscribers and growing serves 120 ml
and registered users across 200
companies blah blah blah
the deal provides the opportunity for
crunchyroll and funimation to broaden
distribution for their content partners
and expand fan centric offerings for
consumers king this is your topic what
are your thoughts sir
my man jim dance fools ryan has done it
again
just when you thought it was over he
said but white there's more
why are you excited about this deal all
right so check it out right
how can you squeeze more juice out this
orange right jim said i'm gonna make
more money in areas that you've never
heard of you're like what we got fun
amazing alright right
all right so microsoft just spent seven
billion you know on xenomax
they they really got the western rpgs
right now
they brought more and more yeah they
brought more developers and stuff like
this
they're making mad games right now so
what we gonna do
we going where they don't go
we going to anime baby
let me let me bounce back a little bit
are you saying
are you saying
that might that that sony
is is a little bit you know they're a
little bit shook from microsoft so they
feel like they have to go into an
entirely different industry to make the
the ends meet just in case you know what
you're saying no what i'm saying is sony
is taking eight bucks in a different
area
microsoft ain't got no anime right what
we gonna do becoming anime gods they
want to become the gaming gods in the
western rpg
we want you to watch naruto over here
new anime come out you like that berserk
we got berserk so it hurts baby we got
so much berserk
that's crazy like right now
raise the price on your playstation plus
just so you can watch more anime
you
so right now
all you guys get laughed it up get ready
because it's about to happen
so king what happens if i'm a
playstation consumer what how does this
benefit me
well you like anime don't you yes i like
anime there you go
[Laughter]
all we're going to do is add some more
money to your subscriptions so so king
art are you implying that playstation's
gonna they value me as a playstation
customer so they give them they're going
to let me
bundle
crunchyroll and funimation with my place
they love you they love you they say
since they say our games and movies
anyway why don't we give them more
y'all
messiness king are you implying that
they could they they do the movie games
well so they going and they got down in
the movies they're tripling down
now this is this is more of what their
fan base wanted i know i didn't hear
this is exactly what they're looking for
so if you love anime like i love anime
you won't see attack on titan where on
that playstation 5 which
because is got a next generation console
to watch old generation anime
wow you're messy sir you are messy
moving on to jake and hopefully get the
voice of reason here
this kick is out of pocket but um jake
when you heard this this whole deal you
know obviously funimation the
crunchyroll you could totally be about
to smoke jake
what were your thoughts about it and
then what were your thoughts also this
potential rumor that somehow some
potential that they may
into what would weave this into a
playstation plus subscription tier or
something
how do i follow that like stand-up
comedy act that was incredible that was
like perfect bits mile a minute that was
so good
dude shout out oh my god ah totally
should do
so i didn't actually think about
anything playstation with this until i
saw you guys your show notes before this
just because
i saw the news and i was like wow that's
right sony's a big bajillion dollar
company they make that tv they make that
stereo they make
all these things uh so i stay here
so that was really my first thinking i
was like wow big company doing a big
company thing uh but
that's makes them like the powerhouse of
anime right like i feel like funimation
crunchyroll like that's like
a lot of it like they just gobbled up a
lot so that's going to make them a
bajillion more dollars
the only thing like if if if that rumor
is true i'm down with it because
while it's not
games and i think that should be the
first priority right on the other hand
like if sony has it
they're gonna like they're gonna smoke
what they got so
i don't mind it being a value add of a
subscription or something like that
they
sony didn't they experiment a couple of
months back in
poland
doing his research
playstation some movies yeah playstation
video video pass that was they were
expected it was found out shout out i
gotta plug the whole team lord to
gaming.net shout out to hector le
chatelot macho he actually posted it on
the site and yeah to your point jake
yeah they they have found out that they
were messing around with rumblings of a
playstation video pass and the team and
obviously we also hear rumors
potentially i don't know if anything has
happened since with netflix and anything
like that so yes back to back to you you
know as far as where you were going with
that i do think it would be really funny
about that if they didn't if they didn't
actually develop the movie part it's
just anime
like we know who you are right we know
you're a gamer here you go take this
like there you go here take some anime
kids
it's cool it's cool
would a service like this interest you
specifically no
[Laughter]
no no no i'm not really i'm not really a
big anime fan i watch like i watch the
big ones i watch them a lot more when i
was a kid big fan of big o if it has big
o on it i will then you win that whole
show you got that big o all right no
doubt no doubt let's get exactly let's
get the lord of anime himself lord
addict um how big a deal is this man
sony owning funimation and crunchyroll
educate us addict
it's it's a big deal in the anime
community but i don't think they're
going to do much with playstation here i
think they might be able to leverage
owning two of the biggest you know
streaming services to maybe get some
exclusive anime games in the future
because you know obviously they're
building up partnerships with these type
of uh with these type of businesses so
they'll have a little bit more of an
edge it's kind of like them being a
japanese company and they have a lot
more relations with japanese companies
but as far as like oh they're gonna
bundle this with playstation plus
nah no exactly actually
your eurogamer has put out the article
that they're they're saying that this is
what this is leading to
well that's cute people said the same
thing about funimation and that never
happened so so you wouldn't you would be
opposed if you saw no i mean i don't
care because i already have a
fundamental account so like it doesn't
really matter like i'm not gonna bundle
my playstation that i rarely play with
fundamentally encryption
what what what if whatever you an anime
guy what like you see jay got like the
big o like what if they got your
attacker exclusive
you gotta go get that over here i got
that on fundamental what they gonna do
exclusively
the exclusive episode it's gonna be i'm
making up a fake scenario
let me have my fake scenario what if
they got exclusive
attic anime content on playstation you
can only get it in the team
i can't even acknowledge that statement
because that's not how anime works like
maybe maybe if they got like you know it
coming up more shows
like newer shows yeah but like as far as
like they're not going to like walk
on top like
it's like a bethesda deal you ain't
getting that content
you want the
the thing is though
the thing is though is unless they pull
it off of the xbox or the smart tvs like
i could just watch there but what if
they do
what you call it they had a gate oh and
the daredevil with all that disney yank
that stuff off what if they get real
aggressive with it but see they own the
streaming service they don't own the ip
like crunchyroll owns a couple ips but
nothing like massive like they own the
they're literally the middle man oh you
want to stream this to our people okay
here you go people all right that's
literally who they are they're not the
person that that they're not like the
netflix or the disney where they own
these ips and they lend it out since you
said something that was very very
educational for a lot of people
sony paid one point certain billion to
become a glorified middleman
stupid yeah that's actually that's
actually pretty accurate like i feel now
did you say that real quick just because
you i'm going to let you go real quick
now that you said that they spend that
just to become a glorified man you see
the difference between real bosses
seven point some odd billion to get
zenimax and they own them
right
they paid one point somehow
um
a middle man like
you don't own this stuff but we can just
show the stuff that's it that's all i
just want to say i'm sorry i'm just
saying like
money works that's how business goes
i'm curious like if they merge
fundamentally crunchyroll to your point
like i think they might
go with that avenue and merge them into
one service yeah and it may be the
reason that they didn't bundle
funimation into playstation plus is
because they always intended on merging
crunchyroll whenever that was done okay
so they didn't want to do that twice
they wanted it one time after the merger
so you know that something like that
could happen but like as far as this i
think
they bought this for anime right you
know they might use it to to buff up
playstation plus i don't know if they
will but they they they're like look
gaming's popping the movie industry's
popping we need more we need more
more money and more different markets
and i feel like anime they let's be real
that's a japanese art right for the most
part they're like we already know the
majority of the players
let's get our let's get in there and
they bought funimation what's funny is
they can out bid
for anime but they can't do it for
gaming
no no
king am i not right
you're telling the absolute truth
no no they keep getting outbid by
everyone under the sun when they try to
get these studios but when it comes to
when it comes to anime yo let's spend
one point four billion dollars
doesn't it i'm gonna turn into what your
priorities are
right i mean because any okay i think
anybody right here right hold on let me
say this real quick
i think
i think the reason that they're tossing
that kind of money is because they have
a real defining foundation for gaming
and they know that they could use the
studios but they don't need the studios
but they need the fundamentation they
need the crunchyroll because they want
to be a player
if they want to be a player in that
market they're going to have to have an
established thing and what's funny is
for people that go around clowning
microsoft for not you know nurturing
studios why didn't they nurture a crack
crunchyroll why didn't they nurture a
fundamentation like like when you want
to be the best in that franchise in that
industry sometimes you have to buy the
best like
i'm not fair enough
for some balance here
your thoughts on this and the whole
situation with uh playstation plus
potentially i only think it's really
relevant as a playstation plus thing
if they add it to the service without
increasing the price really
that ain't happening
and therein lies the problem right
you've already seen that microsoft is
willing to sink money into into game
pass
they added ea play they added all this
and they're adding it without increasing
the price may we see a price increase at
some point in future sure
playstation isn't making this play
without increasing the price it's just
not in the books for them to be like
increase value without increasing prices
uh solve the gate pass ultimate was
created right and they all right the pc
ver pc and cloud streaming as a tier
correct
so they could say hey playstation plus
stays the same but if you want the
crunchyroll the funimation all that but
at the end of the day
people when they added that value right
the crunchyroll stuff is value right
yeah then you create a different tier
and i think at that point you lose it
almost doesn't make sense to add it to
ps plus okay because it's so game
centric and crunchyroll they're gonna
add it to playstation now
yes
that makes sense that's that's no that's
how you think about that i didn't think
about it that's the play because
playstation now is the streaming uh
content that they have right it's the
streaming platform that they have that's
like to me
what's the point what's the point in
giving people option to
bundle a service people are already
paying for it yes so like to me that's
just make that so like we're gonna lose
money you want them to have they can
make so the thought process is to make
people get the additional service of
playstation now is what to me
to me
you're selling games to gamers you're
selling anime to anime watchers you're
not trying to mingle them like that yeah
the only way you mingle them the only
way you mingle them is if you don't
charge extra for it and you just add it
and then that's not that's not a cost
they're gonna eat they won't eat that i
got something that is going to blow your
socks what you think blow my socks off
they're off right now put them on and
then you can blow them off
on you first i'm going to say here
okay pause on you and your socks
all right so all right
the business
little being went off and on top of mine
now um like addict said uh maybe they
didn't do the whole funimation thing
because they always had eyes on getting
crunchy bro right so you get crunchyroll
this crunchyroll thing came
really fast in the sense that after the
netflix deal went down
um they are trying to leverage something
in this space now we're talking about
streaming arms right netflix is
the absolute uh
king when it comes to the streaming
media that we have at this moment right
now as far as movies and stuff with that
content and they're actually doing
really good when it comes to anime
because i've watched a ton of the anime
that i really love that's on that
program but
what if netflix says okay um why don't
we
merge with sony on certain aspects on
the streaming aspect of it right
do it with the playstation now because
we're trying to figure out how can we be
reaching for the stars okay yeah but
sometimes i hit these stars because i'm
96 percent right all the time 95 sorry
96 is isa um
and this is the business talk
you merge
your playstation now
with that funimation with that
crunchyroll in the playstation now and
you tag that on to a netflix plus
subscription i'll see you guys
and the netflix plus subscription
reaches
yeah there it is
this turns sony into a juggernaut that
we have never seen in our lifetime at
all from any major platform let me
finish really quickly
and
the streaming arm of it is actually
easier because that's what netflix's
main aspect is there's no downloadable
they're not worrying about that they're
worried about streaming it right
now
you get the funimation into there
automatically they become the the
defunct
hub
for all animation
every last drop of your interactive eyes
is done there through the anime you
bolstered the whole anime catalog they
were trying to get into games at the
same time yeah we heard they were trying
to engage then you have the streaming
aspect where netflix can throw a couple
of games into the playstation now
streaming aspect of it
i think this is because you always got
to look at partnerships as uh what do
you give me and what right from this and
what can i give you and what can i gain
from this i see netflix gaming getting
into gaming through sony and i see sony
getting a stronger arm through streaming
through netflix i think this is crazy
colin colin was talking about this and
and he he talked about how that
if you think about the the netflix
streaming platform right i don't know
how that would apply to gaming right
right obviously they need help in that
regard right in terms of you know we
know they have something going on with
azure we don't know exactly what that is
let's say
the streaming tech that they use in
netflix is applicable in the same way
that it would be the games right and it
is considerably more robust and powerful
whatever the case may be to king's point
that type of partnership would put them
on a level kind of with with an amount
of reach right that we haven't seen
before right and then and then i want to
ask jake this too you guys touch it on
something you know we did hear rumblings
that they were looking into having a
direct competitor to game pass right do
you think what either potential
obviously seeing the the founding
foundation blocks of this whole
crunchyroll thing funimation almost a
monopoly on that anime in a sense and
then
the rumblings of like what king is
saying a netflix
and whatever type of partnership or
integration whether it be playstation
now playstation plus
do you think that plans to see it for
them to be really competitive overall
for the for their services what do you
think about the chick
oh jake yeah i'm curious about this one
i i do i feel like
i i don't know i almost like the way
sony has been talking about things
in contrast to xbox in all regards like
every the way they state backwards
compatibility the way they talk about
this their messaging their mission
statement
so i almost would rather instead of just
it being oh this is this is
playstation's version of game pass i'd
rather them get weird with
it that's the only thing like that is
leading me to think that that could be a
thing is what you guys were talking
about this like weird netflix rumor them
buying crunchyroll you know like there's
something else
there that they could do they seem to
want to very much do things differently
so
i wouldn't really
i i
personally i haven't been banking on
just like a playstation game pass type
thing okay
when it comes to like the netflix thing
the reason i don't think that's likely
is because
netflix is a big uh contributor in the
anime community too yeah if anything
they have more going for them in terms
of anime than crunch your own
fundamental combined because they
actually spend money they have a lot of
original anime
uh netflix only titles so to me like
trying to combine them in any way
actually like defeats the purpose and
nintendo going over on the uh not
nintendo and netflix going on that
avenue because like they're spending
millions and millions and millions of
dollars securing their like seven deadly
sins making their own stuff so like to
me bundling with crunchyroll and
funimation kind of like defeats that
purpose because like
when it comes to anime they're the only
two left they're just the last two
standings
isn't these guys the bigger these two
the again i know nothing of this world
this is you this is all you that's what
i'm asking questions i'm not trying to
be funny like
if they have their own content is what
you're saying right netflix as far as
anime content specifically they have a
lot of animals that they've made right
but we do we hear that these two are
also
dominant in the space right
there you don't feel there's any
room for the uh partnership or that they
would still be competing against them
no because
they they both have their own original
stuff uh separated to their own
platforms but to me
putting those together why would you
spend that money with like to me it's
like you might know what might as well
merge the services at that point right
that's where i was kind of going
well i don't think they would do that
because netflix has spent so much money
establishing that anime market until
like
to come i feel like if netflix wanted
crunchyroll and funimation it would have
happened a long time ago they wanted
some kind of relationship
like instead of spending billions of
dollars establishing and building this
anime community that netflix has he
could have just spent that money and
just merge crunchyroll and funimation
not fair enough
there's also like the the culture clash
where you know netflix is one type of
company and sony is very much a japanese
corporation at the end of the day and
they are very well they'll fight they'll
fight interesting the way they do things
yeah yeah so you know i i get what
you're saying with the netflix thing it
could be uh what uh whatever whatever
i'm a guffin not a mcguffin
i'm not a non-starter yeah i'm
straighter
did you finish your point then i'll wrap
up oh yeah i mean pretty much i i think
to your point cog i think this can be
sort of the beginnings of of
having that quote-unquote sort of um
competitor to game pass but i at the end
of the day still comes down to the
ability to download games natively right
and it's never going to truly be a
competitor until they're willing to let
go of those first parties day and day
and until that happens
it'll be they'll have something that's
kind of sort of like it but a direct
competitor
nah fair enough look at the other day
just for jokes tv tv tv
i had to say it i had to do it just for
joe just look i i i think it's a good
move i think um you know at the end of
the day i know gamers probably don't
care you know what i mean but there's
there's going to be interest i feel you
know for for that for that genre and
people want to animate okay
and fundamentation has improved since
they bought them right like so their
their app used to be horrible now it's
like a step above horror
question not question do you think they
are capable of doing the bonehead
whatever you say no they're not
bonehead thing
of
of forcing the crunchyroll on you oh
that's the struggle right
and bringing the price up
let's see oh
listen
i told you i told you you shouldn't have
jumped again
people people can say what they want so
you're saying they're going they're
going to murder them i'm saying do they
capable are they capable of buying they
bought all of this
did you say this is the new playstation
plus line this is it it's playstation
plus
the thing is is crunchyroll got like a
hundred and some million subscribers
like they're not trying to upset these
people they they're trying they're
trying to do what microsoft's doing with
these studios let's buy the studios you
you control how you sit how you sell
just send me a check at the end of the
month well yeah i think how much does
this country roll on its own like if
just just to 1.2 billion dollars you
know i mean like how much is it to to to
to use on a monthly basis what's the i
think it's like 10 i don't know i don't
have crunchyroll i got funimation yeah
look at the end of the day i
i think that's too much of a stronghold
me personally i think it's just way too
much of a struggle i don't think for
them it would be funnier it would be
funny plenty of cons at the time it
would be funny but i honestly think this
to me sets up a tier system for them and
the same way you know it's just the
optional thing if you want this hey for
five dollars this playstation plus
ultimate you have this and whatever it
may be video pass or whatever it is that
they're trying to do with tv and
animation is what i think and at the end
of the day like i'm i i understand the
move you know so that that's what i got
but look we got to get out of the show
super long and we jake's got to go to
the bathroom
he's a
robot i don't want to make the man feel
like we got him under the rest
twice for help
he told you he was going through this
damn podcast
i told you jake
but it ran down oh you had
with more indie or previously exclusive
third-party games from other platforms
eventually coming to game pass are you
more inclined to wait for them to
release in the service king
the choices are a
no i will not wait on a game or game of
the year contender i will buy it
regardless of platform
b
yes the value of game pass is a
no-brainer especially if i know the
other the game on the other platform is
a timed exclusive
or c
i don't care y'all better boys doing
free labor for these developers
please rock the vote when it goes up on
iop the legendary jake baldino staying
the marathon rocking with us the entire
time because video games podcast and of
course game ranks where can the fine
people find you what else you have going
on sir
uh game ranks i'm uh before you buy
videos and i do a news show every friday
on game ranks i've been doing it for six
years straight never taken a week off
nice it's the most fun we have with any
videos on game rank so if you've never
watched i'd say just tune in fridays
it's the video with the all caps titles
that's what we have the most fun
uh and then i'm on twitter and instagram
at jake baldino at youtube.com jake
baldino where i'm working on
uh i got a hot matrix video i'm putting
out next week
12 minutes
but yeah i'm revisiting all the matrix
movies because i'm really excited for
the matrix
let me get on record now let's get on
record next get it with how reloaded is
good
and
that's i'll leave you guys at that i got
a question i had a question for you
since you're talking about that real
quick do you uh buy into the conspiracy
theory that uh john wick is because neo
uh decided to take the pill remember at
the end with the architect and he
decided to go back into the matrix and
there's a reason why john wick is so
incredible is because
real third world
so if you ever just just i just i'm gave
you some food of thought right because
uh just think about it in that manner
the reason why john wick is so
absolutely incredibly ridiculously
awesome and it's tough that he's able to
do it because he's actually neil and
he's been de-powered not to remember
what's going on in the matrix
no longer the anomalies
i didn't really see neo get like jacked
up like like john whitby getting hit
like well he's the power to actually
feel like he belongs
let me correct something uh i i didn't
mean like subscribers i'm in like
overall money like okay like yeah
because they only have like five to ten
million subscribers i mean like the
money they generate
all of that yeah
but now jake we're looking forward to it
man like i said glad we get this done
this was so much fun so much the most
fun i've had in a long time thank you
brother i mean you've been killing it
and love what you're doing i'm still
waiting for that you're gonna have to
explain yourself with terminator being
better than terminator 2 but let that
slide
until i see the video and until i get
your proper explanation before i pass
just watch that video okay i work extra
hard for it
because i would terminate the two
fanboys i think it's the goal i think
it's the best salute to you on that love
the content love the video thank you for
spending your time brother really really
means a lot to us you have no idea and
of course you know you thank you guys
you guys what you do is also incredible
thank you thank you so much
thank you means a lot lord solve where
can the fine people find you what you
got going on sir we got to do super chat
we will after yeah we do yeah no doubt
oh yeah big shout out to jake for coming
through man like again like the whole
idea of just
on youtube be yourself
do what you love and and go into it
wholeheartedly jake you've been doing
this for over a decade like honestly man
and
i love the fact that
it's all about
being honest to you to yourself to your
fan base the people that watch you i
think that's one thing that that from
the very beginning like cog is like
we're just going to be ourselves here
and and that's going to work and you
know king believed in it from the
beginning and and and this is where we
are so big shout out to you love your
content
[Laughter]
no doubt so uh you guys can find me you
know what's up you can find me on bx
opera and psn xbox live and lordstop ilp
wanting all the smoke on twitter
apparently spicy spicy
smoke
i don't want it i didn't pause i don't
want it to wake once
on my youtube channel you follow me on
twitter uh that is the gaming addict
with the c that that's attic there okay
that's the smoke addict uh the you know
unlike stuff i want to smoke
i don't mind the smoke i live in the
smoke
so you can find me retired from smoke i
don't want smoke
there you go i'm an old man i'm an old
man
yes you're you're a year older than me
jake so i have a little bit more time
before i have to retire
if you're doing that poll or whether
people in chat would pay higher for a
higher tier plea playstation possibly
yeah they want that poll
with that i'll do it all right thank you
sir thank you sir but uh you got
anything else going on too besides
before i pass off the kick i'm going to
be doing a uh bro uh a uh sky resort
video here soon i still ain't beat the
game
uh well what i really enjoyed about
skyward sword 2 real quick is like how
they reused areas because a lot of games
do that really bad like they'll reuse
areas and you feel like you're just
playing the last area just in a
different way but skyward swords like
they're like nah you're gonna you you're
gonna go back to this area but it's not
gonna be the same when you win it the
first time i can appreciate that i
definitely want to uh you know thank
jake for coming on here one thing you
know i was listening to some of the old
interviews that you've been on which you
ain't been in a lot of interviews per se
like you know
this it's really hard to find
you know besides uh gamerx it's hard to
find you in any kind of concerts on
youtube yeah and uh i i was watching
your jeff grubb interview yeah
oh yeah so i'm watching it uh you know
shout out to grubby grover
and you know what you said something on
there that i really gravitated toward
like you know what like that that's
awesome you said i don't like putting
miss information out
and i was like because that's something
that we're always big on like we want
you know
even it comes to big stories if it like
launches on a saturday sometimes like
we'll be like let's not talk about it
until we get all the information yeah
and you know sometimes it's easy to jump
on that that bandwagon yo let's talk
about everyone's talking about we want
to be in the news but sometimes it's
better to wait for the proper
information than spread misinformation
because we wanted to jump on it first
yeah we have a whole catchphrase we i
say i say it every week i say keep uh
you know take this with a grain of salt
that's like the catchphrase we're gonna
put it on a shirt eventually because
like i feel like some places don't
differentiate enough like and really
emphasize like when you talk about a
rumor you know let's say the grand theft
auto trilogy rumor that just popped up
like you have to emphasize like we don't
know
anything like this is just reporting
from an unnamed source like we don't
know anything so we're just having fun
don't put any personal stake into this
you know no that's real and keep in mind
realm if you want to see more uh jake
he's got his own personal youtube
channel you can go and check his videos
out at gamer racks man you you always do
like you always do like
some of the best reviews that's done out
there because i do feel like
a lot of reviews feels real scripted but
you could tell like you're just like yo
this is what i feel about the game like
it don't like it i don't care but this
is my info
thank you and i i i always try and i
always try and i kind of ran on the
whole thing where like when i was you
know like when i worked like retail jobs
and stuff and like you know there'd
always be that other friend in the you
know in the in the frozen food
department
and he'd be like oh yeah i play games i
played uh you know that game and i'm
like oh you like games well did you know
this and did you know that and did you
know that oh you exactly
that one that's like a little too much
you do i've always just tried to keep
that with my videos like before you buy
and stuff like that like i'm like
yeah but definitely go check him out man
uh you know thanks man first thing i
want to say is we are doing that podcast
i don't i think we agreed on the
roundabout table didn't yeah that's what
we agreed on yeah uh so we're we're
doing that podcast i have posted to the
to the members and patreons uh you know
you guys can ask questions we're giving
one uh one each a question and if you're
you're double dipping you get asked the
lowest two questions exactly uh i think
we'll be doing that i think we said next
saturday right yeah that's when you can
do this because it's really unsolved
when it's eight jobs it frees them up so
we'll be doing that so definitely go to
your patreon go to the members put look
for that post uh post ask the questions
man we'll be talking about that it will
be pre-recorded we'll post it on both of
those uh those chats independently uh
you know and the first one is going to
be public because we want to you know we
want to show you guys what you will be
getting if you do do a members or
patreon but here's the catch we'll only
be answering questions from members in
patreon we won't be answering you know
other questions because we do want to
give some value to the people that do
support us in that way and you all
support us you always come through here
like you know
iop would not be where it is without the
realm the fact and we do appreciate
everyone that comes through here
you know that's why we try to keep the
chat as clean as possible we want people
to feel comfortable talking in that chat
even chris righteous
even chris hart like we we want people
that's in that chat to feel comfortable
and we appreciate everyone for coming
through that and especially our mods we
have to give our mods uh that shout out
to no doubt no doubt and don't forget
the poll for um shiny because yeah i'm
doing it i appreciate that lord king
y'all what you got going on sir
well first and foremost i would like to
uh thank uh jake for coming through um
you know strong island that's what's up
with you all right
you know
uh uh so are you at uh pax uh
and you know i've and i was like uh to
caught us like that's the camera right
so
you know at that point in time people
don't understand that
you've
worked
they don't know when you go to these
shows you're walking around you're doing
interviews you're working your legs are
tired you're mentally drained and you're
still working in your head because
you're editing in your head on how
you're going to edit your video
they say the end results they they see
that they don't interfere
yeah they don't see me
like emotionally and physically
destroyed
promptly said the correctly said the
dark ages
yeah and you know to to to hear about
your content where
you're you're getting that love so
that's why when i talked about that
matrix stuff you see like what you did
with the guy when you said the guy uh
yeah
i remember i'm that guy too like so do
you know did you think about this like
that that type of stuff
yeah it's it's always be enthusiastic
with your stuff and you bring that
across so well and i love that heart
aspect of it you know uh it's it's very
hard for people to say that they was in
something for 10 years and still have
that enthusiastic feel to it still bring
that that that realism to it and still
stick to their morals yes um that part
means a lot because um the fact that you
didn't go over to the criticism this is
why that game sucks yeah that that type
of stuff um
click baits especially if you don't see
i hate it um
you don't see
your numbers going up or you don't see
certain things happening at a different
time but to stick by your guns and be
real to yourself that means more than
anything like means more than any amount
of subscribers that will inflate and
deflate at any period of time because
your core base will still stay the same
and i just uh love the fact like i was
telling cod um sometimes i get nervous
about videos and i was like this is
really weird like i'm not nervous about
this video because i guess it feels like
i've known you for 10 years already or
so so it's kind of crazy right
i appreciate that that's absolutely nice
and again also your your candle metaphor
wouldn't you you use for burning
yourself out yeah that's that's gonna
stick with me like i feel like i'm gonna
always remember i've never thought of it
like a candle and now i can't think of
it any other way so you know
if you watch the fir uh the interview
that uh you know the lords did with uh
me and pd and jj
the first time i remember you brought up
that you ate like cereal the first
i rock with him he's from the grind
continue
that's literally the definition of
someone coming from the ground floor to
where he is now
yes
you guys can catch me this week yes
um friday
mm-hmm dcx is back baby
you heard it here
nice dcs is backstage
stand up yeah
this format gonna be a little different
ah
you will really like this this is gonna
hit you different all right so as you've
seen uh there's been an uptake in kos
like you're like boom oh wow boom oh
statues right so
um people i know that i'm a huge
spider-man fan and uh you saw what
electro
you're seeing with the lizard if you can
look up there you see sandman is up
there um i have his whole
rogue gallery whole sinister six except
for scorpion and i'm trying to get that
statue i just cost three thousand
dollars and i'm not trying to do that
right now um
but again
kos is going up this is going up this
week and i got a secret unboxing that
i'm going to do and you guys going to
get a chance to see the red room he's
finally unboxing the statue of himself i
wish right shout out to acg
telling me to get a statue
but this secret statue is going to be
unboxed and i'm going to do the kos from
the red room but you're going to see the
statue first and only at dcx nice that's
when it's going to go up and then after
that i put out the video you catch me on
twitter at king david otw if you thought
i was going crazy here today you will
see me go [ __ ] bananas on twitter he's
very spicy yes all that smoke all that
smoke that they talking about i'm about
all that smoke bring it this way i'll
take that uh
lawsongaming.net please go there please
check out our guys well i feel that is
the best
gaming news site on the internet uh if
you can get a chance to go there and
check it out i'm pretty sure that you
won't leave you will actually stay there
please go check out lor cognito with
ibontis ibontes wasn't there this week
he was thai guy travis with him and they
put in their work i'm actually got to go
finish that video uh addict got
something else coming up i'm watching
this stuff every week because of my son
this is kind of messed up but i gotta do
it
i love the guy the devil with my son
sitting there like daddy i love his
stuff oh god
[Laughter]
no doubt but again like i said
tremendous episode again thanks jake for
pulling up love what you had to say love
your journey how you like you said grow
up in youtube but then also your the the
decision you've made
to keep it positive and to not always
focus on that because it's it's easy to
fall in those traps and you you've
created a lane for yourself and it's
just cool to see your journey man and
again absolute pleasure to have you
we'll definitely have you back and once
we get back to these shows in person you
know what i'm saying one of my favorite
in person actually one of my first in
person real interviews of anybody so
you you were there was one of your first
that was one of my first yeah
you know what's funny jake because like
you know uh this is like a little bit
behind the scenes like
like part of the uh the the audio
adapter oh god
because i didn't go to that pack said i
was i was driving home and calling he's
like yo can you fix this man i don't
know what happened i was like yo just
rush i was like i was like just come to
literally the right's the exact same as
the left i'll just copy the left and
print it on the right
like shout out to attic because again
you're doing content creation you're new
and interviewing people you were like
the biggest interview i've ever like
period and i'm just like yo
and then this audio thing happens so i'm
freaking out he's like nah i got you bro
i can fix it i'm like all right cool
cool you know it was such a big deal you
know what i'm saying for us and the fact
that you took the time shout out to
sonaldo who was in the chat who just had
to be he was with me you know and we
were making our rounds and it was really
cool so again thank you the fact that
you went though from from me to
now you got big phil yeah no big deal
in such a short period of time you guys
that's incredible thank you brother
actually it meant a lot that for you to
say that you enjoyed it and stuff like
that and the last point i'll say is
again for bigger content creators to and
that's why i have that model like i
don't care how big i get or my star i'm
never going to forget because it's those
moments right it's those moments you
always remember and i always want to
thank you for that so salute to you lord
jake jones dino my man so look we got a
ton of super chats we held your hostage
so you could bounce if you need to
because we got to pay the bills so it's
cool if you want to do your outros it's
totally cool but we got to read a ton of
super chats remember remember jake blink
twice if you're on the street
but jake it is all good i do have to go
let my dog out yes please
enjoy yourself you guys again for this
opportunity yeah let's link up oh
[Laughter]
yeah let me roll back a little bit okay
glass this time i give up please
try to do that without don't be hot
try to be hot
one second oh was it smittysmith
no we're at home
while you're looking for that uh someone
just break a good point
members that's in the chat uh go ahead
and put some questions in for that
podcast now and i'll i'll come to this
part of the podcast later and write them
down
so any questions that the members in the
chat want to ask put it in the chat now
and then i'll come back later and i'll
uh i'll i'll copy them and put them in
the show
this is crazy
we got horus to two dollars which that
cod will come out first and halo will
take its knees
[Music]
yeah 100 correct
keep in mind people like that you know
gotta have that that little icon man
that jester that king i can't remember
what the rest of them are
or i can't ask them man you got to have
that little so if you want to be in that
show you got to become a member during
this show so you do we could even i
think there's an option on youtube you
can set it where they can only members
only get to chat why don't we eat
dragons
yeah we got 108 dragons 5 super chat
good afternoon my guys good afternoon my
brother yo
and we got smitty smith 5 super chat
sony you get anime you get anime
everybody gets anime just don't forget
to blow into your control yo
the book of x
[Music]
and we got jw as a shill 10 super chat i
thought we bought consoles for games so
xbox gets bashed in 2013 now the sony i
mean sony fanboy the soy oh my god sony
fanboys i hyped for crunchyroll well i
own all of the bleach chapters so i'm
good hashtag we now believe in anime
then we got raider blade firefighter
super jack king you said it from the
very beginning that the ps5 is a
built-in credit card and the price will
increase big time
that's how i got sovereign knees
once again people throwing out
misinformation
for the rumble and the audio sound and
the lip sync yeah exactly
we were talking about the console there
not the services
thank you
people conflating all these things thank
you allowing this man to say hi we got
super chats
playstation is about to get caught from
behind like nasty nate styles
okay phil dominus max aurelius spencer
and squirrel master won't be there this
time to save the sony wow
yeah that nasty yeah i was not feeling
that too
nasty
yeah yeah that's not
destinating his lizard let's go
oh great and blake fireball super chat
hashtag christopher heart reply to me in
color your comment is muted to me in
color bro if not keep your comments
yourself ladies and gentlemen let us
behave in the chat what's going on no no
keep it that way
if he can't follow you with a certain
space then leave him in his face
[Laughter]
then we got marvin ginyer two dollar
super chat actually calling off roz um
fyi zagrius in greek method mythos is
the god of rebirth so it's a perfect
perfect name for him exactly
then we got brian seals five dollar
super chat netflix would love to get all
of the anime ever produced yes
it's true if your member your members
don't have the log out to see to see it
all that's a big win for your service
that will kill this is what i'm saying
sony brings something to the table that
they can't get anywhere else and
remember netflix is dying to uh to
dominate in that space if they could
bring those two entities together yeah
there's a problem
and we got raiden blade five pound super
chat is that ps5 abandoned thing it's an
app and not a game i feel it's a demo
platform and ps fans have been
hoodwinked not nice for them
whatever this abandoned thing is it's
just going on for too long that's the
crosstalk
yeah
and we got fat boy horror let's go put
the question [ __ ] that's my favorite
yes sir repping this repping the ilp
swag
he loved that sega podcast we did oh
yeah yeah yeah beautiful
damn we got the rubber now
five dollar super chat i said it the
other week mark my words you will see
tap dance ryan come out at e3 on st and
say tbtp
come out with a neurotic dog yeah
we're caught up we're good we're good
that's good no doubt that is what i got
anything else we got to do in the
business in
no uh people are definitely coming up
with questions right oh okay
i appreciate you
we're gonna make it a good show man
there's there's a lot of people just ask
questions oh no doubt yeah we got a lot
of stuff cooking up man again oh just
for update uh spoke with king so yeah
little man is coming literally oh man
put it in the hands of a guard yeah we
put it in the hands of the gun so these
oh y'all i think
um he got a chance to hear my viewpoint
on yes um exposing the individual now i
got to figure out a way how to just warn
the community yeah from dealing with an
individual but at no point in time do i
want to weaponize yeah anyone against
anyone for anything especially if
something as little as the funds that
were uh you know asconded i i i feel you
but i'm not as diplomatic
did you notice that sovereign faith got
complete
you you would think i'm the most
diplomatic one i'm actually the least
diplomatic i understand i explain to all
you people that ever watched we are all
the same person just in different skin
very careful
but yeah we got a lot of fun stuff all
cooking up enjoy a couple more weeks we
will move to 11
80.
week one of football nfl we'll be going
oh god yes that and it's 17 weeks this
year yeah but no we're not doing a whole
joke we're rocking all the way till like
january it would be good but look that's
all he said oh we're not gonna do the
whole joint we're just gonna take it all
the way to the limit
baby
that's all i got everybody enjoy yo
sunday we out
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]